what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I have
taken over Coach Greg Adams Studio what
am I gonna do man she took over the
studio for the day yeah I'm the captain
now you're the captain now all right all
right let's get it going before I start
guys don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos also guys sign up for
our new membership tier the fourth tier
is a one-on-one call with me once a
month to help you grow on social media
okay so let's start
um
tell them a little bit about your
channel uh my channel is called the
coach Greg Adams channel uh that's one
of them the other channel is the free
agent Lifestyle Channel and uh what I do
is talk about men's issues preliminary
uh pretty much around divorce and
marriage dating lifestyle travel
and then we also talk about getting your
money right and all that stuff yeah so
um are you would you consider yourself
red pill mgtow or neither uh probably
red pill is the space that I uh probably
would be categorized okay but we promote
the free agent lifestyle over here okay
what's that the free agent lifestyle is
men's guide to Peace Quiet and freedom
right so it's a level up between uh men
who don't date then men who are in the
active Market of pursuing a lifestyle
that's going to be more advantageous to
them in our world the world that it
exists today all right that's the free
agent lifestyle yeah and how did you get
to that point like what did you have a
red pill moment I've noticed a lot of
guys in the space like there was like
one moment that maybe was their red pill
moment uh men unfortunately get their
red pill moments right we get we get we
get introduced to life because we don't
have the advantage right of being
selected early and often many of us
don't many men do but most of us don't
and and we go through trying to succeed
with women right that's where the void
is we try to succeed with women and then
ultimately we hit that moment of reality
that's that red pill moment we get some
double dose of reality or we hit our
head five or ten times for me it was a
marriage then a divorce and then
re-entering the dating Market as a man
that was uh married for 10 years and we
I re-entered the market dating
Millennials and gen Z okay as a man who
was married in a stable household for 10
years almost 10 years okay that that was
the introduction like this is different
something's different than when I was
pursuing my wife and then married her
and then lived with her and then there
was a new world out there so that was
the red bill moment what was the bigger
shock the divorce or the dating scene
the dating scene the dating scene yeah
the diversity kind of saw coming yeah I
mean that's just kind of the the natural
course of things obviously I dealt with
some legal issues related to the divorce
right and so that was a red pill moment
it was like what is this but it wasn't
the thing that got me right and a lot of
people think they watch my content and
they're like that's the thing that got
him and he's just mad his marriage
didn't work out we actually parted ways
amicably but the divorce grinder that
was like what the hell is this right so
at that point I was getting some
information but once I was re-entering
the dating Marketplace that was when I
was like something is something's up
what is the divorce grinder oh the
divorce grinder is when lawyers get
involved in your marriage right and so
what happens is they gotta they gotta
they got to separate the marriage they
got to separate the two people legally
which is not easy many times people will
be married for five years and it takes
two years to get a divorce
and it doesn't make sense so you're
dealing with the legal issues of
detaching two corporations which is the
husband and the wife and people get a
reality check of what marriage really is
can you tell me a little bit about the
divorce laws the divorce law okay yeah
so because that's one thing when I first
entered like the red pill space yeah
two-parent household my parents are
still married so I was like why don't
these people want to get married I'm
like it's a I'm like it's a it seems
like a great thing right I come from a
woman's perspective it seems like a
great thing yeah from a male perspective
is not why isn't it because the state is
attached to these marriages essentially
you're entering into a business contract
this is the stuff people get pissed off
about talking about because it it bursts
the fantasy bubble yeah right what I'm
going to talk about is like oh but what
about love and what about kids yeah but
it's still a business contract so what
happens is most marriages gonna end in a
divorce and the laws are going to be
dictated based on your country or your
city or your state so they're all
different and if you just happen to so
get divorced in a place where the law
suck then it's going to be a worse
experience some people get divorced in a
place where they don't suck or they just
halfway suck so it just depends on your
state like California for for instance
is considered one of the worst places to
get divorced I was getting divorced in
California
so my whole perspective of divorce is
like whoa all right these people uh look
there as a matter of fact some of the
most wealthiest divorce attorneys are in
California so they have an incentive to
people get divorced they want people to
get divorced obviously to stay in
business and when you find that out the
divorce laws are then introduced to most
men
at that point
now my content we've introduced the
divorce laws to men before they get
married
so that gives them an idea of what
they're getting into most men aren't
introduced to divorce laws until
the woman says I'm divorcing you and
then it's done because the women were
basically paid to leave aren't we you
have great incentives yeah what
incentives are those great incentives I
mean incentives to be supported by what
they would call maintenance spousal
support or alimony those are all
maintenance special support and Alamo
they're considered the same thing just
depending on where you are what state
you are those three words are used
interchangeably but uh oddly enough
feminists are opposed to that as well oh
they're opposed to that most staunch
feminists don't like maintenance or uh
spousal support either this is what
people don't understand they think
feminists are just going to agree to
have an advantage in the Family Court
they look at that as a negative as well
because they want to be able to be
self-supportive in all of that stuff so
yeah really the feminists I've talked to
and I I I'll tell them to get a job
instead of like trying to cash out some
feminists are not really feminist we
attribute their or we use that as a
blanket term to describe people who who
like the red hair or crazy feminists
those are those people typically more
agree with many red pill guys there's
just a kind of different call to action
I think some people ride the wave of
feminism they're not really feminist
so and then what about child support so
there's you got those yeah child support
yeah tell me about child support of
course the the evil empire
so you have child support so you have
the spousal maintenance or or spousal
support
and then you have child support which is
a second payment
it's calculated completely different
from spousal support spousal support
dictated on how long you were married
and that's like alimony okay yeah so
depending on how long you were married
or who was the primary Breadwinner which
typically is mostly men because that's
how women select but child support is
based on how many kids you have
if I have kids in a prior relationship
if my income significantly greater than
hers it depends on what state
so then you can get a double penalty you
leave out playing spousal support and
child support and they're both sometimes
they're both collected by different
agencies so I yeah because that that was
the big like shock to me is like women
are basically because isn't child
support dictated by how much like who
has the kids
so it almost gives women incentive to
take the kids it's a fight for the
custody yes yeah because then they get
more money most typically you're going
to hear a woman say I want primary
custody right right which is going to
mean she wants an advantage on that time
wise uh what the the excuse they'll use
is that I raise the kids I was a primary
uh parent he worked he traveled he was
never there he cheated whatever it is to
get out of that he can't take care of
them because he works a certain schedule
he travels he's an alcoholic he's an
abuser that's why he shouldn't have the
kids that's how this Frame but we have
to understand that there's a calculation
gonna give her it more money the more
time she has but here's the trip you
want to hear something funny when we
when we say that most people say nah
that's not the case she just wants more
time to give the kids more stability
right
but men will say I deserve my parental
rights to have the kid equal time
you know what the woman would say in
that situation
he just wants more time so he can pay
less child support
uh oh so it's like a little it's like a
lose-lose yeah because I just said she
wants more time to get more child
support so they then switched it back
and say he just wants more time so he
can pay less child support
yeah and that's that's what I I really
did not understand when I first started
watching red pill content I was like I
was like why are these guys so against
marriage like this seems like a great a
great thing yeah I mean in in if it was
controlled by Church controlled by
communities is it is this is how
communities are built so people think
that I'm anti-marriage but I'm pretty
traditional in the in the aspect of the
best way to raise children in a
two-parent household I know that I
understand that but we can't even do
that we can't do that as a community so
what happens is the state has to get
involved and the state has to do its
best to find a way to support women who
are now being
volunteering themselves out of marriage
but they can't support themselves 100 so
their state you know there's resources
that they reach to eventually and then
there's also a penalty to the guy saying
well you married her so thus you have to
support her to a certain extent and for
a long time it was like you have to
support her forever then they put in
rules and laws to say this is you're
going to support her until she can get
on her feet I get a job that's right
yeah but you're also saying the women
who volunt who said I quit my job my
career to be a mother and a wife you got
lucky right that's what I said I'm like
why are you entitled to money half the
time they're the ones leaving half the
time it's almost damn near all the time
wait well and even that statistic is
skewed right so we say 70 of divorces
are filed by women and then 80 or 90
when it's college educated but that's
but that's skewed because a lot of times
women won't file the divorce to punish
the man
oh shut up I've never thought about it
so what happens is that the guy says I'm
leaving you for another woman
well legally she's not going to file a
divorce
because he's going to marry another
woman or he's going to be out there
dating so in order to prevent him from
finding another partner she'll stop the
divorce proceedings or at least halt it
yeah so there's a lot more so then but
by that point the guy says I'll file so
then he files and gets the process
started that's only one because
otherwise he knows he's going to lose so
so the divorces are that are filed by
men or don't even count as the man filed
it is the woman that won the divorce but
she won't she'll drag the proceedings to
prevent him to marry wow you just red
pilled me a little more well you here
with the master you hear what the number
one the notorious CGA you in the bunker
right now so because I was thinking when
I when The more I've learned about the
loss I'm like a guy that no wonder they
stay with the whales
what what whales the fat chicks oh
um yeah well again that's another hang
up because a guy can't divorce the woman
he can't divorce the woman because she
gained weight yeah that's a disadvantage
but she could divorce me for gaining
weight yeah oh he got us a lazy slob
these whales on my page
oh yeah
it's the Pillsbury this weekend over
here
no no I did um a clip that was going
viral and all these wheels started to
show me their blubber I'm like she'll
meet your brother right uh man most of
the time these people uh obviously the
guy didn't marry her in that state many
times so now she's not who he married
and we call that a baiting switch yeah
that's what they do they get the ring
and they're like and then they're like
I'll just let myself go and there's no
penalty for her he gets penalized for
letting her go and that's the that's the
other penalty but I'm gonna give you a
third calculation that nobody remembers
that I have to teach people about and
this is where men lose more than 50 so
you hear that phrase men lose half well
men typically lose 75 of their income or
resources because the third calculation
is how property is divided how pensions
are divided how
um retirements are divided how um you
know if you had a business how's that
divided so there's a there's those are
three separate calculations when you go
through a divorce and typically if you
had a guy and you were a business owner
or you had a military pension or a
firefighters pension and then you had
kids and then you have spousal support
that's three income sources that are
divided in the courts and it gets ugly
so okay so if you so this is your house
yeah yeah so so if you got married again
I'm sure you want it never gonna happen
I'm saying you never gonna happen again
yeah but let's say you did you know
tomorrow right now then you get divorced
how what would happen to the house
um depending on what state it would be
considered either community property or
it could be used to up to the judges
just a discretion to decide
so oh so he can just give her the house
good because that's called Equitable
Equity what's Equitable so there's
Equitable States like Texas is I believe
I'm not mistake don't don't quote me on
the states but um some states are
Equitable
um whatever whatever's Equitable but in
the judge's mind 70 would be Equitable
and accurate that could fly but a
community property
well that's a problem so if the judges
or simps or you have a female judge
what's gonna happen right what's
typically going to happen
um in in California it's community
property 50 50 which creates a problem
if I split this house 50 50 I can't cut
it in half I can't put tape down the
middle of the and say you live on that
half and I live on that half so
typically uh what happens is the guy
feels like he has to move out uh I'll
just move out you have it but he can he
be moving out but he also was paying the
mortgage but then and then she can go to
court and say he hasn't been in the kids
lives right because it's not one thing
they'll do the girls will do like he'll
move out to get out of the house or
while they're fighting and then she'll
go to court and say he's well that's why
you don't move out before the divorce is
over right but typically a guy gonna
move out before the divorce is over so
he don't get killed and poisoned
on accident he's like uh be safer for me
to be out of the house because you know
he got to go to sleep where is he going
to go to sleep they're gonna sleep in
the same bed well I was
explaining this to my dad right because
my dad my dad he doesn't know about
anything okay he's he's getting
enlightened now tell my father and and I
was telling him I'm like if you had like
if you got divorced tomorrow and you
split it with Mom right and I was like
you would be fine because he's I'm like
you're a super productive guy right and
I'm like
but do you know what I'm saying like
he's so productive that he would be fine
but I'm like there's guys that like work
their whole lives to build up some and
they're not the type of guys that like
are gonna start a business tomorrow and
just remake it I mean it's it's bad
either way but like I think sometimes
like certain guys
don't feel as much like empathy I guess
because they don't they're like oh I
would be fine oh Eve would be fine so
he's not worried about that situation
well if you had a guy typically we call
a great divorce guy so he's a little bit
older he's worked a certain amount of
years in his company and he finally got
to the top peak of his income and then
we call it she pulls the road from under
his foot right so he finally worked hard
enough to be able to pay off the
mortgage pay off the house and then at
50 she pulls a plug
so everything he worked for is flushed
down the toilet if he moves out of the
house yeah and he's 50 at that point
he's 50. so he got to start over from
25. oh [ __ ] and um because that whatever
he saved is going to get divided in
court so he can't just be like okay keep
the house I'm gonna go
right he's going to divide the savings
too they're going to divide the
retirement too and then he's going to
have a monthly obligation to the
children and he gets penalized he
basically pays daycare uh payment to the
mom to keep the kids and why why is it
so one-sided uh well at one particular
point it was the other side as you know
in our society right now we're going
through a pendulum swing where
everything's you know men are
complaining this isn't fair and we're
being penalized for privilege of the
past
so there was a time where the kids went
with the dad the mom got kicked to the
curb yeah there was a time in our
country that we had that and the woman
would just get kicked to the curb she'd
be an old maid and live in the [ __ ]
dust cover or something like that you
can I don't know if I could thirst today
oh okay all right yeah so um but uh yeah
that that was a time and then they came
up with
um in the slip in my mind but they came
up with um the there's an English law
where they said
and they studied this they said kids
were better off with their mother
oh God she slips online they're better
off with their mother when they're young
essentially when they're young but it's
like over the age of seven they're
better with their father over to age at
seven eight they're better with the
father yeah but uh somebody will put it
in the comment section and educate the
people but um I think it's called
something child Doctrine or something
like that but um what tends to happen is
they the pendulum swung and then women
started to get more favor in the court
and then men mostly said hey I don't
have time to raise kids anyway so I'm
gonna go work and it was not a big deal
child support was just getting
introduced in society so there was no
penalty okay go with the mom but then I
guess people would say men had an
incentive to dump the woman to the side
as she got older go get a new wife
recreate another family and leave her in
poverty so you see where the pendulum
was over here and women were like this
ain't Fair
why am I getting penalized so then the
pendulum swung all the way over here
State got involved child support laws
now we're over here but marriage has
lasted so long that couldn't have been
that common or was it was it very common
replacing your wife yeah yeah old idea
yeah
okay you know I was just thinking like
the marriages lasted longer before the
70s so I'd imagine it was less common
like that must have been less common
than women divorcing their husbands it's
less common than what we see today yeah
right the divorce rate is way higher
than what we've seen in the past the
girls are hitting 40 back then they're
like ah no well if you look at what
women used to look like they're hot they
were they were very regular right they
were very regular compared to now
typically the 40 year old woman you see
today is manufactured
you know I'm saying like the girls back
then were skinnier they were skinnier
they were smaller yeah
but you know they couldn't be on the
marketplace putting themselves back out
there to find another man at 40.
oh yeah yeah
at that point it's going to be harder
for her to go find another man but it
was common to actually marry multiple
times
like that's why the divorce rate was
high back then because people would get
married three four five six times oh
interesting I didn't know that
right right you couldn't just be out
here you could womanize but it couldn't
be public you had to be married there
was actually Community kind of like you
know you don't have a wife
um
Great Gatsby that was like the 1920s The
Roaring 20s yeah but those those Roaring
20s then like our Roaring Twenties
twenties
back then they might hold to 26 and then
push the chips they said I looked up the
definition of a spinster Spencer yeah
how old 30.
26.
26. so you had Old Maid yeah Spencer
yeah left over I mean these the things
that we're talking about now is what
people are they're like what but this
was common knowledge by a certain age is
over
yeah you're gonna be at forever you're
gonna be an auntie forever you know no
more kids for you but now we've trumped
it with science well you guys you guys
just well not even that I feel like you
guys just bail us out
yeah no I just mean like like men always
bail women out of their bad decisions
it's not even a choice right but we're
telling men don't do that because it's a
it's a lifelong sentence that you're
giving yourself like you become a step
daddy to bail out a woman
well even outside of that I'm talking
about like government benefits you guys
pay more into government benefits and
we're the we're the ones that are on
them
I mean that's always been that way
though yeah yeah so I think it's worse
now they pay you to be a single mom in
the UK you get free housing if you're a
single mother right but that was
annoying so I was like I didn't have any
kids so can I get rewarded there's no
equity there's no fairness in this thing
here but you can go out there and get
knocked up if you want I think I think
the crazy thing is the problem men have
today is we've been educated that men
women are equal yeah at a time where
women were taken care of them and bailed
out there was a sense that men their
little providers is the role you provide
over here right and then if you didn't
provide that role you get kicked the
hell out and say all right you ain't
cooperating that's it or if he was an
alcoholic and abusive he loses that's
what divorce used to be but when no
fault divorce came in then it changed
the game and it swung the pendulum
swiftly to the point where now our
generation and younger we're dealing
with the realities of these women are
equal but I owed them child support I
gotta fight for my kids
they get alimony but we're equal in
society it doesn't make sense how did
how did no fault divorce swing the
pendulum the noble divorce allowed women
to get incentivized to bust up marriages
with no excuse
see before you needed a reason you
needed to hire a private investigator
and follow your husband to the hotel
with his secretary
right or you need to have been abused
you needed you needed a reason they
would have to go to the court and say
well why are you divorcing this man at
that point women didn't follow 80
divorces they probably filed probably
less than half men probably follow the
divorces but once they said you don't
need a reason
divorce rate skyrocketed and then women
can go in and say he's cheap um I'm he's
worth more
divorced than married
well and then you see a lot of the
government like programs come in too the
government programs like the the welfare
and that type of thing yeah and child
tax credits and all of these things like
that yeah because I'm like why are we
paying people to be single mothers
that's what I don't understand
well you incentivize people to have be
single mothers and of course they're
paid to do it and I remember when I
lived in the midwest when I was younger
women would stay getting knocked up by
multiple men yeah they would be like and
there would be mothers telling their
daughters to get pregnant
and that's why teenage pregnancy was
super high because the mothers would if
they were if the women were shiftless
and lazy as mothers they would have
daughters and the daughters would be 15
and 16. they'd be like girl you can get
300 a kid a month
and so those girls would have three four
kids
and then it's a vicious cycle because
I I cringe to think that 300 a kid is
free money I couldn't do it but if you
think some people are like that's good
money yeah
I mean it's like to me I think it's
absolutely crazy but to uh put to a
person who's a loser
they're like I could get money by just
having sex and getting knocked up and
had that three four tie and had that for
25 years essentially they have it for 20
25 years yeah yeah three or four kids
and even if you have
um different fathers you get more per
father I don't know if you know that no
I didn't know that okay
so so let me get this straight they're
paying women not only to be single
mothers but they're paying them to get
pregnant by multiple people correct so
if I let's just say for instance I had
four kids by one person the state will
acknowledge that right
but if if if she has four different men
but they only have one kid right that
person can pay more in child support per
kid but I have I have three I have four
kids with her and I have another kid
over here I'm gonna pay less per kid to
her but if it's four different men it's
four different
payments it's it's actually an incentive
for them to get Knocked Up by multiple
men
so it's a game it's a weird game but God
people have to understand people women
play that game they sit around
calculating this [ __ ] yeah and they'd be
like all right come over here and they
get listen I don't know if your audience
knows getting pregnant is hard
well there's 40 that's fine
it just happened I don't know what do
you mean just have there's 41 forms of
birth control there's 41 400 birth
control ovulate like three days three
days a month
protect it and you gotta have the egg
reach the sperm reach the egg which is
mathematically almost a miracle and then
you have to have the baby deliver which
is a miracle I don't know if you guys
your audience knows always tell my
people your Miracles right this act is
miraculous it's like the odds are low
but these people do it three four five
times to me it's intentional it's really
intentional when you see what happens
out of here
um that these people keep getting
knocked up is completely intentional and
then what you got birth control so if I
wear a gun how did I get how do I get
you knocked up I mean the mathematics
and there's abortion too like I mean
yeah I mean like I'm personally pro-life
but like you you can you can get like
right it's if you if you said I can't
afford to have this kid I need child
support and you could have you could
have terminated you could have it's
ended up for adoption you could have not
got pregnant because you were unable to
uh afford the child but but you keep
getting pregnant that's it and I that's
the crazy thing every person I know
that's like had an like irresponsible
pregnancy right they're just Reckless
they're just it was I'm just like what
on Earth to your audience the worst
thing a woman can ever be in life is a
single mother you heard it here first
yeah I agree with you yeah
so I have no sympathy for single mothers
out here although I was raised by a
single mother but I always tell my
daughter never be that I mean you
basically just complicating life and
you're penalizing the child
um and you're gonna just basically ruin
the child that's what you're gonna do
what do you so okay so
you got divorced yep and you said you're
married for 10 years and you got almost
10 years you got divorced and then you
entered the dating scene yeah dating
what was that like uh These Hoes crazy
out here no uh what was it like I I got
an education in the uh Generation X and
Millennials quite different
so younger Millennials tend to they want
to push off marriage as long as they
possibly could my generation was not
quite like that it was getting to that
point but but uh Millennials typically
like 29 30 32 34 but all the but before
all of that it was going to be in these
streets right they were going to be out
here straightened more times than a
Holland Tunnel all right so they were
going to be partying we call it the
Holland Tunnel in New York so they got
ran through more times in the Holland
Tunnel and the Holland Tunnel was the
busiest tunnel in New York it goes from
New York to New Jersey okay busiest
tunnel almost in America and a lot of
women started to
show that that's the lifestyle that they
lived Sex in the City yeah I'm gonna
live over here and go over here backpack
through Europe and blah blah blah and
then they were going to say oh I'm
irritable material now
well the the mayor's rates at plummet
since this generation that that
generation Millennials but they will say
Millennials are staying married more and
all of that stuff but they're not being
honest because they're still young many
of them are barely hitting 40.
so yeah that's now but you know there's
a generation there's there's Baby
Boomers getting divorced right now in
the 70s right so just wait give it time
but dating wise I thought you know let
me give your your group your audience
some context when I got married and was
um engaged
there was no dating apps
there was no smartphones
there was not even text messages back
and forth they started making phones
were
um
47. by the time you guys see this I'm
47. I'm 46 right now so
there was no we had pagers and stuff
like that and little link pagers but we
have no smartphone where you could just
get an app swipe swipe swipe that was
2002. I think uh 2002 when I got engaged
2004 by the time I got married so that's
what that was and even dating they had
dating websites like match.com was
around I believe and um there was other
things but um you were a loser if you
were on Match
you were a complete loser like you were
a loser you on a dating site loser
so the idea that you couldn't get your
person out in the open
right that was losership so with that
being said I got divorced and and
separated 2012.
their smartphones now there's Tinder
there's plenty of fish there's now
Bumble uh there's Instagram it's just
starting up so that's what I got
reintroduced in the daily Marketplace so
it was like a highway it was like a fast
moving Highway when before it was a
crawl isn't did you when you did you try
to like Court some like hoes at all
foreign
I think uh what happened was sex was
much easier given see this is what the
crazy thing is to get sex when I was
about getting engaged was tough you got
to work you had to talk to the woman and
you you couldn't you know unless you
just met a fabulous 304 right and you
were just lucky that night remember it
was getting lucky there's no such thing
as getting lucky it was just almost
guarantee so by the time I'm getting
back out
um Instagram had just started becoming a
thing this was the baby infancy of the
Instagram and so I'm getting divorced or
during Instagram's Peak through people
were girls were flying in themselves in
they were flying themselves in girls
were driving hours I mean it was just
like what I called the digital sexual
Revolution
and it was nothing like that when I was
getting when I was uh married or
situation like that yeah it was not like
that so what what did you find out about
female nature like through this
um
like when I found out about female
nature
I just think that uh by that time I'm
gonna find out how you doing on your
yeah that's good I keep checking that
we're good we're good
female nature at that time
I think I was learning that what they
say and what they do or two separate
things right okay so that was basically
the Epiphany I was like they're saying
this but they're doing this they're
doing this under the cover of night but
they're out there I'm an angel you know
what I mean like that type of stuff and
I'm like this is crazy
so that probably was the epiphany
and um to not to not trust what they do
because I think what what people will
tell you and I will tell your young men
whatever your belief system in women is
going to be validated by social media
and dating apps so if you think girls
are out here being pure
well based on your experience is that
true most of the time if you're using
social media and dating apps you're
going to find out that there's a lot of
fast and loose women then that's going
to validate what your belief system is
going forward and backwards right you're
going to look back on the relationship
then my girl disappeared all the time
Friday at eight o'clock what was she
doing you know she was learning how to
use her easy bake oven or she was
getting piped down right she getting
right now because it's easy
so you will know that because you'll be
the guy piping women down that Friday
and you know when she goes radio silent
on her guys that she's dating she got
multiple options and also when you get
that uh text message this is the text
message I don't know if it's popular now
but um the uh oh I fell asleep
you know you text him at eight o'clock
oh I fell asleep she text you in the
morning I fell asleep uh you know I'm
getting back to you well based on your
experience you know that that's not true
she was getting ran through it as we
called it over here she was getting her
insides pushed her esophagus that's what
she was doing she wasn't just falling
asleep you know so what about what about
the guys that say not all women are like
that
I mean people will say there's no
unicorn there's no any of that type of
stuff uh if you believe that all not all
women are like that I tell you roll the
dice roll the dice bet on her
and then you'll find out whether you're
gonna win or lose but I think we talk in
generalities here I can't talk
specifically about who does what but I
have some women that I would thought
never was 304s and when they got to the
crib they was full on 304s and then vice
versa some women I was like she is scab
pill and skeezer and then all of a
sudden she get to the house and she's
all nervous about things you know what
the hell's going on
it's all different yeah yeah so
um
tell me about your interview can we talk
about the interview yeah we can talk
about that that seems to be going around
like wild right now yeah that's like
going crazy right now yeah
um
yeah I got invited to the show and then
um you know Hafeez was there and
obviously people wanted to see the
debate between our particular content
but I didn't know he was going to be
there
so I showed up and I was like what what
we doing what yeah but so I never
considered it a debate I just recorded
the interview and said what I said they
were asking me questions directly and
then they would see if he disagreed
that's basically how the debate went
so I was on trial
and then he would just basically get a
chance to
responded what were some of his
rebuttals I I've watched the energy yeah
but remind me okay I would say most of
his rebuttals I think what he's trying
to stand on is trying to have a balanced
conversation right so he looks at people
who are in The Red Pill space is
imbalanced uh I don't think that's an
authentic argument because we're content
creators as well so if you want balance
I mean I think what do what you're
trying to do is tell me the torpedo my
lane and my channel channel what are you
trying to tell me to do because we get
we can have a balanced conversations by
having two different opinions
but my opinion is this like so if I'm if
I'm saying my channel is about Ferraris
and then you want me to tell me tomorrow
yeah I interviewed him the next day okay
okay
yeah so look i i people he should know
how content works right yeah that's
where he's all he's not authentic
because he knows how this works
and now you're telling me to be balanced
based on your interpretation of how it
works but that's not a that's not the
conversation that we have on social
media I think people
tend to subscribe to channels
that have a certain message
period now if you go off that if I
invite you into my channel and say this
is what we're talking about and the next
day I flip to try to have a balanced
conversation that's not authentic but
then his argument is well you're only
doing it for the money look this is how
social media works you know what what
are we doing here are we going to have
our authentic conversation about how
social media works or you want a
balanced conversation but it can't be
both
what do you
should men get married it depends on
your position so I tell men and uh a lot
of people get this wrong they think I'm
against marriage
as a principal that's wrong I'm against
state-sponsored marriage and I'm against
men getting married without information
most men get married both right they get
married stay sponsored and they think
they're getting married under God or
they get married in their church or from
their community and they're not anymore
okay it's state sponsored then most men
get married when they're in a position
where they can't
uh provide whatever they need to provide
to the to the wife of the marriage and
then that's how they get divorced so
they get married and they have nothing
they have nothing but love nobody have
love our love is like no other love are
you saying that doesn't last
love yeah love is love does not last
it's not intended to last
[Laughter]
love is not attended the last actually
most people even even people who are
pushers of Love Will Tell You Love lasts
18 months maybe three years
but this is why it's important that you
actually have something else to build on
other than love but if you want to make
your decisions purely on love what
happens when the love ends
and then you're gonna have to deal with
that so this is why children are
important right so if you have love love
is basically basically lust
confusing you to appropriate that's
nature it gets this attachment it feels
good I hope everybody experiences it's
great as you get older it's less and
less for for men you'll experience it
less and less this is just how it works
I think that's true for everyone yeah
they use love to manipulate men into
marrying them when they're when they've
already been ran through so this is the
pair bonding argument so they'll say but
but I love you but she needs rent to be
paid yeah that's what it is or it's like
that was
um
yeah that's what people girls get so mad
on my show when they say that what I
love them no no no not that like the
pair bonding oh the pair bonding yeah
yeah but I'm like I don't it's like they
tell on themselves though because
they're so angry yeah like why are you
this why are you this man you shouldn't
be Rebecca you shouldn't be this man
well the proof is in the pudding all I
say is just look at the results that we
have out here if you have for women
unfortunately if your sexual partners
pass a certain number
what you're doing is manipulating it's
not love there's no way it can be loved
now you can be attached people have to
understand love and attachments are two
different things and you can tell by
when the relationship ends if you had an
attachment or love see a person that had
love they'll be have their feelings hurt
and then they'll be indifferent to the
person they may be like well I just want
but a person that had an attachment is
like a parasite they'll try to kill the
person they'll hate the person after
they broke the attachment because the
ego's involved there was never any love
what they'll do is they'll go attack the
person
oh that's interesting yeah it's like a
parasite parasitic relationship so once
the once the host shakes the parasite
off the parasite hates the host right
right
that's that's attachment and so if they
loved the because he I almost think like
okay because when I think of girls like
I feel like the girl if she hates her ex
she still loves him if she hates her ex
she's yeah yeah because you don't like I
feel like hate is closer to love
if a girl doesn't talk about him like
then she didn't care okay so but but I
my rebuttal of that is you don't destroy
something you love typically if there's
hate involved she's trying to destroy
embarrassing them that's ego so what
she'll do is drag him through divorce
court take him to child support trying
to penalize him and hurt him take the
kids away don't let them see the kids
that that's not that don't come from
love that come from Pure ass oh yeah I'm
25.00
I don't know anyone that's been divorced
but I'm just thinking like like in in my
shelter and my in my friend group I know
like older people but I wasn't kind of
young I guess you know what I'm saying
the what the junior college but my
audience
what is it junior college is a young
woman
typically under the age of 25 between
the ages of primarily 18 and 26 is you
your Junior College age oh okay yeah
yeah
they don't know they'll be in the
comment section okay I did with the
junior I graduated but you know no you
still Junior College oh no I'm graduated
it doesn't matter oh okay a lot of
people still in school okay okay so
um the what were you talking about I got
her shuffling now all right so we were
talking about you never seen you never
divorced but I'm thinking like keep
girls my Edge like I feel like if a girl
hates like if she's like I hate my ex
I'm like no you still love him I guess
younger women would probably have that
because they have the ability to pair
bonds to you yeah yeah right they have
that pair bond or she's been imprinted
by that man so she hates him but there's
a reason why and you have to figure that
out she hates him because she lost them
she hates them because
um he won't give her advantages and let
her manipulate you have to figure out
what that is but because you're dealing
with a younger group of women they still
have been these are the first few men
that they've been with so yeah the hate
can be generally come from love it could
be that Dynamic once they're older than
that 26 it comes from Pure manipulation
and and uh trying to penalize the guy
yeah
yeah man oh women evolved man you got to
take the you got to take that man women
evolve and a good Predator a good apex
predator
a good apex predator evolves as they're
out there out there in the jungle Yeah
man they gotta survive
women have to survive
and just think about this just think
about this women
don't get physical mostly in our society
like think about since 200 000 years
you'd be surprised I've been well
attacked
right right but typically to survive
they've been able to get underneath
survival uh mechanisms which would be
either government men cavemen uh
shelters they've been able to do this
and survive they're still here I mean in
any sense of the imagination if they all
had to get physical they'd be dead
if there was no transactional
relationship between men and women there
would be no women but obviously there
would be no species right so with that
being said women are survivalists
and they will do things to survive even
use love
as a means for survival
think about this think about this the
first cave woman
you know she might have had a nice rack
or a pretty face or something like that
right and she and then she figured out
there's a saber-toothed tiger out there
gnawing on my ass
do I want to keep running every day
or do I want to go to the guy that got
the cave up up at the top of the
mountain the cave yeah yeah
I'm kind of afraid of tigers
physically wise
no right right yeah
so what you gonna do I love you cave man
and by the way you can have access to
all this down here if you want that's
what you like I'll be up in the cave
yeah yeah okay yeah I could see that's
yeah right so that's a form of
manipulation okay but it's a
manipulative tactic not against the man
it's uh to survive okay so you think
like at our base we're manipulative
women
men and women are but we're also
participating in a transactional
relationship right so when I say
manipulation manipulation doesn't mean
bad
manipulation is just manipulation
whatever you got to do to survive like
for me I gotta go out there and become
you know a good mover of stones and
build that's manipulation and then I'm
also gonna say I'm gonna get I'm going
to be the man with the cave with at the
highest mountain so I can't get the best
hey [ __ ] or whatever you know what I
mean like I'm I want the best woman I
want the best cave woman my cave is at
the top you never have to run from a
tiger
that's manipulation
otherwise look look if I don't need no
cave women I wouldn't make a cave at the
top of the mountain okay but I when I
think of manipulation right I think of
something being like dishonest about it
do you know what I'm saying that's how
we've been told yes and maybe maybe I'm
incorrect so maybe I've been using the
word incorrectly that's possible but
when I think of manipulation I think of
like well I think it's manipulative to
lie about your body count
I think that's manipulated sure it is
yeah but absolutely yeah but I think
it's not manipulative if a guy is just
like you become the biggest strongest
fastest and then caveman you know right
but manipulation sometimes like you can
just handle something that's called
manipulation I'm manipulating this thing
right I'm not doing something evil to it
I'm not using something against somebody
else I'm just manipulating it when I
think of that term like I think if some
things did so if I had the equivalent it
would be like a guy lying about his
money that would be a manipulative
tactic yeah yeah yeah yeah right and
people use that
and they use that all the time
yeah but I would think
I guess I would I don't think I don't
think a guy
to like build him out
himself up to be the best guy he could
be I wouldn't think of that as
manipulation I could be wrong oh I see
what you're saying so you're saying
you're saying it's always got to be
accompanied by a lie manipulation and
lie is synonymous I don't think it'd be
synonymous I think they're basically
we're misusing the word right and that's
because we have a negative connotation
to manipulation but
but what I'm saying is what what we're
doing is transacting
we're transacting but the manipulative
part is somebody convincing us we're
doing that I love
oh that's the manipulation
check this out
I love you so I provide for you okay yes
so you love me so you work so hard in
life to provide what if you didn't have
access to me would you have worked so
hard
probably not like if I knew I wasn't
going to get no women I'd probably be
like what's the point that's what a lot
of guys are doing now what's the point
of going out there and trying to date
because look at what what I'm getting
I'm getting whole staff peeling skeezers
and whatnot right so check this out for
women
for women if they don't use love
yeah we're good I just check it every
now and then it's good though it's good
okay if if women don't use love how do
they transact how do they get the
relationship
if we don't use the sex
yeah okay but or you know they used to
have like um finishing schools finishing
schools so she could be the best woman
she could be to provide something in
excess right now it's just sex I would
say for most for most women which is
dumb but but you know there's cooking
cleaning you know uh yeah I mean those
things are can be outsourced those are
outsourced now because women want
careers I'll tell you man I tell you
women
typically have fumbled the best
opportunity in the history of life and I
think young women are figuring it out
and that opportunity is they had a
better situation they were convinced
that they could get a better situation
many of them are finding out they're not
as happy as they thought they would be
pursuing careers and job they end up
going why am I at work I could have laid
on my back for my husband and did these
other things to fill in the void cooking
cleaning and child raising and all these
things which you know women don't cook
very well but
that's neither here nor there they're
not the best cooks neither the best
cleaners but that's what they had to use
to transact a relationship
this is all transactional yeah
people think there's some feeling
involved with it but the feeling yes
there is feeling but that's not going to
last long like two years it's gonna last
two years and then you're gonna say
loyalty time commitment like those are
the things that make a relationship
so when people say well what about love
go have some love I mean but it's not
gonna lie as a man that's known that
part is if you base your relationship
purely on that
do you think men and women love
differently absolutely yeah how so well
here's the thing women women want to be
loved a certain way and women uh men
just want to be loved
right so women want to dictate how
they're loved and men just want to be
loved so women are the receivers of love
that's what I this is what I believe and
in turn the woman gives respect back to
the man
however that's not what we're doing
today that's what's messing up the
marketplace so women want to dictate how
they want to be loved let me explain
that so I can provide Love to You by
displaying it by demonstrating it I can
support you I can come home to you every
night I can make sure I only have
children with you I can make sure I
don't embarrass you and have other women
out here in their neighborhood I'm not
screwing the whole neighborhood of women
and embarrassing you right I provide for
you
I I bring everything that I do out in
society I I do I do for you
that's love
that would be in the long-term frame a
more survivable form of relationship and
love that guy's displaying it he doesn't
have to express it in words
you don't have to write poetry
he's not going to come home every night
I love you darling
but women want guys to do that
they don't care about the display they
actually say that the displays of Love
they're entitled to that you're supposed
to work for me you're supposed to do
they call it the bare minimum that's a
bare minimum what are you talking about
that's everything
that's how men do we're not expressive
we actually do we I want to show you
when we give you when we when we want to
be endearing to a woman we will gift you
something we'll bring you a rock we'll
shine a rock here you go it's the best I
can do but these people are like give me
your spoil me give me a date here and do
the please so women want to dictate how
they want to be loved and then they find
out that their list is is what we call
5011 uh uh 50 to 11 things long he has
to do this this this this this this this
this this this please man nobody's gonna
do that not when you out here
fornicating with everybody you could
possibly do it man [ __ ] man we ain't
doing all that but what happens is on
the vice versa women love on the
conditions that you do everything she
has on this list otherwise you get no
respect back both people are wrong just
so you know
both people in today's world got it all
wrong why well first of all women are
out of their freaking mind with this
right they've been influenced by romance
you see me saying women have been
influenced uh by romance like men have
been influenced by pornography so Women
Believe romance is something they're
entitled to when it's simply a myth
men want want their woman to be a freak
in the bedroom and experience but then
also don't want her to be experienced
so when she's super experienced he gets
intimidated he'd be like you were a hoe
and she could be a great cook she could
cook for him and clean for us he could
do everything he wants and then and then
he's like well but you were whole so
it's we live in a whole culture so the
idea that he's going to eliminate all
the women down to the no hoes is Slim
the nun well it's like rolling the dice
that's it that's what you see it's like
rolling for a guy on over 25 to find a
woman that hasn't been defiled to the
point
of um she can't parabon like that that
slim the nun he's not fighting that
woman so
maybe you need a new criteria can you
tell me about the term Alpha widows that
was something I learned that was
something I learned in the menosphere
alpha Widow
yeah that's uh the idea that a woman has
chased the top-tier man
she takes to chase the top tier men
she's had the top dogs and then once she
comes out of that and she's been spit
out because that guy has access to
whoever he wants right right and then
she's been spit out she gave her a
chance she hoped to get the NBA player I
dated an NFL player once and I thought
it was gonna work but he had 18
girlfriends in 18 cities right and so
then she got spit out now and what she's
going to do is say you have to be that
guy you have to live up to that guy's
expectations and I'll take no less
please so I have I have a theory that
I've been developing so I I feel like
I've kind of turned into a guy on my
show
the first hand what the men go through
because I recruit from my show right
right and the women are so
funny knows if they're going to show up
it's like 50 50. right it's like I can
text them the day of are you coming yeah
I'm coming well no no warning no nothing
yeah so you know what it's like to date
women right yeah so you're a bisection
I don't swing that way well you don't
have to be in the bedroom but by by what
I said what I mean is but I know a lot
of bisexual women they have the same
complaint they have the same complaint
they're like I like women and odd men
but it's tough date women it's tough
dating women if they're the ones that
are reaching out they're flaky yeah so
now you have experienced that but you
know on this level yes and I'm like I'm
offering you guys free drinks free
podcast
and yeah and so um through this show
I've developed some theories okay
um the first being that women like being
cheated on and I'm telling you I don't
know why I've developed this I'll tell
you why I've developed this I know what
you I I don't disagree with you go ahead
because I'll interview women after woman
right right woman apps and it's like I
just noticed the same pattern right
it's like they you're gonna be well on
your way once you learn learn patterns
of human behavior yeah yeah so you guys
hate being cheese
right
we did correct and every time so every
time when he's cheating I say did you
leave no of course not and so I'm like
okay that's weird like right you would
think you know you would think most men
would think this too yeah so then I'm
like well did so when when did you leave
right he wasn't cheating correct and so
I was like if he wasn't cheating
then isn't that what you wanted
right and I was like do we like being
cheated on it's still it's not that you
don't it's not that you like being
cheated on what what's happening is you
realize that your man has value outside
of you right so what typically happens
is if this is gonna be the opposite if
if you find out no women like me
and we're together no woman looks the
other way nobody inquires I'm a straight
loser and you're with me you're gonna
question why you're with me
but there's no question when you're
getting cheated on that you have a man
with value so for women that guy's a top
top guy so she looks at it as that guy's
valuable at least to other women so that
makes that makes her in a sense want him
more
that's also the same as abuse victims
right they typically don't leave either
that's gonna be my next thing that's my
next my next women
that's my next theory that I've
developed okay because I used to like
when girls would say they were abused or
or graped right yeah I I would just
believe them
exactly because like you know you got
that like empathy yeah and I think it's
gone now for me it's gone right so
you've been Redfield in this yes yeah
yeah because I'll ask because first I
wouldn't really ask questions because
it's kind of awkward right so they're
like I was this this but then I started
to think about it and I'm like
did you press charges exactly you're
asking the right questions and then
they'll say no and I'll be like why well
I was too scared and so I'm like but
what are you doing on my podcast right
you're not scared to be out here talking
about it that's what I was like like
are these hoes lying well the first the
first thing is you got to find out I
mean this is in our society we've gotten
to the point where we're afraid to
question women right so that's called
victim blaming because somehow if you
wanted the details of the situation that
she's you know she's saying is a very
vicious crime
if you want the details she knows you're
going to blame her
so she's like I I don't it's on it's an
inappropriate to question a woman
so now at that point she's got you in a
situation where you just got to believe
it hashtag believe all women so now you
got to believe the believe it and let
everything carry out but like anything
any relationship is going to have some
things that are weird like first of all
we thought of grape as someone some man
jumping out the bushes in the ski mask
then it developed into some dating
encounter then it's now marital
situations that can be interpreted and
then they went away from the word now
with sexual assault that's essentially
what what but sexual assault opens it up
to anything that could be any damn thing
that's okay okay I was on this podcast
the other day and this girl said she was
coerced right right and I and I was like
okay so then I was like I swear did you
sleep with him again
yeah yeah
I was trying to make too too much sense
but but here's the thing there's people
that can claim that their husbands
assaulted them eight years ago in their
marriage but they continued to sleep
with him live with him and so forth and
then she can come out well you know he
did this at this particular point so the
problem is we have a lot of propaganda
out here that's telling men that we need
to take Women's Word at face value when
historically that's one of the worst
things you can ever do I would never
take any particularly women I would
never take their word at face value
because historically they've they've um
they've accused people of doing things
and people have lost their lives and
later to find out
sorry I used to believe him
I wouldn't have never yeah I mean just
like they would seem so sad
and then but then it's like and then you
think about it even further right
because because I just keep I keep
thinking I'm a thinker right and outside
of the norm so yeah so I was thinking
I'm like okay he hit you right
the average guy like I'm strong I don't
know if you I'm okay yeah I'm built like
an athlete okay I play Semi-Pro
volleyball
if someone punched me that's a dude like
my face would be well that's the problem
with with women they might be able to
dish out a couple of hits which aren't
going to be very significant but getting
hit is always different so I'm like if
he abused you why is your face intact
good thing I was wondering is
and then I'd say did you hit him of
course
and she may have hit she may have hit
him first and still claims abuse but
here's a you know I I we so we we have
we want to inform your audience check
this out did you know that uh in
domestic uh physical abuse 70 of those
cases are con are the woman instigated
she could have either hit or used verbal
abuse or emotional abuse to get him to
respond so when there's physical abuse
where the man hits the victim which
would be the woman seventy percent of
the time the woman instigated meaning
she wasn't a passive participant meaning
he didn't walk in the door and kick her
it was instigated by something sometimes
it was instigated by physical abuse on
by the woman so but but these are things
that people can't talk about because in
our societies consider misogynist to
talk about these things and then the
other thing other things
this is the same umbrella of the abuse
the the great I say grace
so so the girls will say tell them
they'll be like
and I and I'll be like oh that's a lot
like my dad sucks people like that sucks
you're gonna go there now but I asked
questions right and one girl sort of
tells me well I didn't know I was great
no no yeah that's so yeah and I'm just
thinking like okay okay
how do you not know right because if I
was if I was great
I feel like I would yeah but you would
have to deter I feel like you would have
to determine if there you'd have to have
a true definition of what that is but
now we've gone up we've had multiple
definitions of what it is
so typically you can have a woman say I
was assaulted
but she only discovered that after her
reputation was dragged in the mud right
so she went to school and she slept with
this guy at a party she went back on
Monday to school and everybody knew
about it and then the girl said did you
sleep with that guy you a hoe then
another girl came did you sleep with him
oh well I really didn't want to oh you
were great see now now now she's great
because reputation is on the line so
these things happen once the reputation
gets dragged you have a person that is
getting raped also you do have women
that do I don't know if people know this
most of these what you would call grapes
aren't violent
most people who report one they're not
normally violent but see the idea what
we have in our head is that somebody
jumped out the bushes and shocked her
and then she was there and he had to
beat her up that's typically not what
women are reporting they're reporting
someone close to them
took advantage or they stayed at the
person's house too long or they were
drinking together and they fell asleep
in the bed and then he or she passed out
and the person she trusted that's what
that's what people are reporting so what
we have in our mind
is not what people are reporting
but sometimes those things are
misconstrued too
yeah man I think most of the time let me
tell y'all something if you drink
alcohol
you're probably you know you're partying
and all that stuff and you're dealing
with late nights those are the most of
the time that are going to get into some
sort of sexual assault
s in those situations
[Music]
they look like I'm crazy
I can't walk home alone at night in a
dark alley and I'm just like what where
are all these dark alleys that's my
first question and two I'm like I'm like
nobody can walk home alone nobody if
you're a guy nobody and at least if I
get attacked as a girl another dude's
gonna help me right right we do hear
that women are unsafe out there we're
unsafe and people can attack us I'm like
I could get a tattoo what are you
talking about like like I could walk
through an alley and everybody be like
oh you're good but um yeah these are all
things that we've been fed to be truth
and that's not necessarily true we're
vulnerable I think men are more
vulnerable uh in instances you know if
I'm dressed nice if I have jewelry right
I could lose my life and actually every
day you know women women want to be the
purveyors of being vulnerable but
um if if I look at a man wrong if he has
a bad day
I could lose my life too I can get beat
up too so we have to always men always
have to be on guard to protect ourselves
from that no I agree like um
I mean it just if me and you are walking
in in this dark alley
and you and you get job
you get jumped and I get jumped right
like if I start screaming another guy is
gonna like more likely to come I think
if you started
I'm not saying either is a great
situation yeah
but yeah it it it's um you know I would
hope that people do start you know at
least they'll call 9-1-1 right if they
hear you scream it might be alerting
because you know women screaming is
evolutionary been a sign of trouble
which do women do manipulate and they
overuse
oh tell me more tell you more so again
about manipulation right so
um you know women have learned that if
they do screen people respond it's like
a baby that cries learns the parent
responds so what they've done is
manipulated that sometimes they would do
this on the playground sometimes they
would do this you know somewhere and
they would scream or they'd go up to a
nightclub and when they're having they
do this thrilling pitch right to gain
attention
right
and it's not because it's an emergency
but she's learned that people will give
her attention by doing this squeal and
as a result
when women squeal now nobody does
anything
like if we if something happened right
now we're recording this and somebody's
screen right now we'd be like I wonder
if everything's all right
we wouldn't jump into action because we
know uh Sometimes women just scream
so they got to shoot themselves in the
foot you know
can you tell me more of these the
manipulation I wanna I wanna
see number if I've ever done one okay uh
what we call the screen typically would
be a simple whistle we call it a simple
wolf whistle so
um women typically will use the the the
argument in public as a manipulative
attack so if we're in if we were here
and we had a disagreement she probably
would just storm off and use the silent
treatment she's not gonna combat me and
jump in my face but if we were in public
she's gone get into my face do something
hit me and she will raise her voice
right not not all women do this but what
I'm saying is this
yeah yeah but what they'll do is they'll
have this confrontation in public to get
people to get attention and then and
what will happen is people will watch
people are going to look and they'll
look as long as she ain't getting beat
the [ __ ] up right now now if he starts
decking her people are going to jump
into action but she used that indicator
that confrontation as a simple wolf
whistle so now now
so the Sims are gonna look right alert
and then they're ready to spring into
action should the man do something now
in most cases that man has done nothing
but but um but we were gonna say he
probably did something for her to be
yelling at him
but that's not the case that's
manipulation oh that's the other thing
yeah what did he do what did he do yeah
oh
oh this is another one she got a lot of
them
four times a week okay I got a lot of
pent-up frustration okay so you're not
learning yeah yeah because they'll say I
went crazy and I'm okay okay okay yeah
and and he no no he made me crazy and
I'm like
speak for yourself right you're just
crazy correct because I'm like I I don't
I'm like I've I've been in situations
where I could have went crazy right but
I have self-control yeah yeah and
consequences yeah and yeah and and I did
not I've never hit a guy I've never you
know like but yeah these girls will be
like and I believe hit her back I know I
know the red one the red pill guys will
be like no it's not worth it and I
understand that but equal rights equal
lefts baby we wanted equality come on if
women attacked me and I always say man
once they throw the first punch it's
it's on like Donkey Kong but I also tell
me and you know you you don't want to be
in that situation if you worked hard to
build yourself up to who you need to be
but but the um what did he do let me
give you an example let me give you an
example if uh this happens in married
couples so married couples will be
married they'll get divorced the woman
will manipulate and use the child
support system and and drag them all
right and then the guy will complained
damn she she hired attorneys she
dragging me she she just won't give me
she won't let me breathe boom yeah
what'd you do to her
yeah she can't just be a [ __ ] like
that's the worst part is like I know at
some point I wonder what he did I wonder
what he did what did he do yeah why
can't she be why can't she be the
perpetrator
I don't know I know that now but before
like I wouldn't have even right you just
you just didn't think of like women like
that of course which is weird because I
am a woman like I don't know why like
yeah well we've been what I tell people
is we've been conditioned significantly
we don't realize it and you only realize
it when you hear this perspective
and you hear this perspective and you're
like damn this is why y'all going in on
all these things because you don't
realize that for for 25 years of your
life for 24 years of your life you've
been educated women or sugar and spice
and everything nice women don't lie if
they lie they tell White Lies they don't
hurt people and um all of these things
right so men lie they manipulate they're
the cheaters and blah blah blah but but
what we know that as is that we call
that um projection
so women that say men are dogs and they
always cheat well people cheat equally
women and men cheat equally if not women
cheat more we're learning that
they would treat way more so I just
think more more opportunity like I think
people are equally shitty that's my but
I think but I think if you if you pay
people to make bad decisions right and
you give them more opportunity which
women have like way more opportunity
yeah yeah and then they also do get
supported when they cheat right
um meaning that their girlfriends won't
tell you know what I mean
why
why yeah what did he do yeah
and then they'll say he wasn't holding
me tight he wasn't paying attention to
me he wasn't hitting it right he lost
his job so you know what I mean that's
there's an out for her she he pushed me
into his like for the guys like I know
you're cheating on me with Derek and
then she says well I eventually cheated
on him with Derek I wasn't at the time
but he pushed me into Derek's arms
wait a minute you weren't cheating with
Derek I accused you to cheating with
Derek and then you eventually cheated
with Derek because I said you cheated
with Derek this is the type of stuff
yeah I
I just the last couple of months I feel
like has changed me as a person oh you
dark hearted now yeah I just you dark
like CGA
what I'm gonna tell you what it is you
want me to tell you what it is I'm I'm
the guy that instructs people of all
this stuff many of the red pill
phrases that have come up that are I I
created it I don't know if you know this
people people don't know these things
many of the phrases that are used now
some people I'm not saying all of them
but very like great I was one of the
first people but that's neither you're
there but I've come up with a lot of
phrases that people use that are
changing but it just happens but I'm
gonna educate you on something okay we
call people you know you have this red
pill blue pill Matrix and all these
ideas
what typically happens is people will
discover truth it could be their truth
or it could be the truth but anyway they
discover truth now you can do one or two
things when you discover truth act like
it's not true
and continue on with your life
or you can actually accept it as true
and then live your life accordingly but
what you're going to do is be awakened
but because everything you're going to
see in your past was a lie so we call
this
accepting if your life was a lie
which is hard for people to do
we've experienced this many times and I
can't say what it is because if I
express it your channel my your video
might come down but when you were a kid
there was a guy that came down the
chimney and all of this stuff right we
eventually learned that that wasn't true
right we went well damn okay
you had a situation should I accept it
as the truth or should I go ahead and
accept this uh uh or act like it's I'll
just act like that's not true because I
want to be able to get my gifts
we actually did the Easter Bunny then
all these things not when you get an
adult you continue to face these truths
but you also have to accept that your
past was a complete lie
do you want to do that most people don't
want to do that [ __ ] and it goes on with
marriage relationships divorce romance
right we end up becoming awake and aware
and people call it bitter because they
want to play in the the untruth bubble
and live a lie their whole lives I can't
live a lie most people who live a lie
they can't go to sleep at night
most people who live at lie I live a lie
they're out of shape and fat
because they think somehow this
miraculous diet and appeal is going to
come along and get them unfat because
they've been living in a false world we
know that that's not true we live in
truth because that means I gotta correct
myself and not live a lie so people
continue to live lives and they fault
people like me and you
for not letting them live that lie
yeah that's all it is but I'm happy
they're not happy yeah and they're on
drugs you know psychomed drugs
and I'm living a great life you know so
because I've accepted hey man part of my
life was a lie
you know they said a stork brought you
to your you know the stork
we learned that your parents were you
know fornicating not fornicating
they were screwing each other yeah when
you're an adult you find out your
careers
that part of my life was a lie
but most people can't do that with
everything
yeah it's
it's time that's that's kind of like how
my channel got like that was the first
viral video like red pilling another
girl I was like
what did that go
okay
it's funny we started we started um
not thinking that trans girls should
plan our Sports
okay which is which is isn't like red
pill necessarily but no it's rip that's
the true Ripper yeah yeah and so then
but then now she like works at the
studio like she's on the show all the
time
so she got out of that yeah those things
are
um you know I study propaganda I study
manipulation we're manipulated by media
and talking points and books and in
education we're manipulating big time
again are they doing it why are they
doing it is it out of evil I don't think
it's out of evil but it's maybe out of
control
to have us on the same page there's a
whole conversation there but we were
told uh we're told our opinion because
most we call them on my show ham and
Eggers and knuckle draggers and oxygen
thieves and mouth breathers most people
don't want to think for themselves right
they just want to be told and have an
opinion now okay okay we're doing this
now that that's what it is and it's just
easier for them some people want to
challenge status quo like I'm
challenging no no no no no right no no
trans girls over here right we want to
challenge that but because how people
are educated we're the Bad Guys
what do you think about women in the red
pill
I I uh because I was actually surprised
you you took this club I thought you
didn't collaborate with women I don't I
do collaborate with women oh okay but I
think that this space is a male space
meaning the leaders should be male right
the leaders the overwhelming prevailing
thoughts should be males in our system
though the women get a pass for saying
this stuff and I get punished you know
what I mean I tell you about my channel
Dynamics and I getting severely punished
for this whereas the women can get to
get this message out so what I tell
people is um there's a certain way I
collab and there's a certain way I I
Collapse so I'm very specific but
women are get been invited to this space
because it's a popular thing now right
do they know do they want to know the
truth or want to be popular that's what
I don't know so I say the prevailing
voices should be male right we should be
dictating what's going on what's said
and if there's a female in the space she
should be coming to the male voices she
should be going to the male voices and
saying what do you think about this what
do you think about that if they're
developing the philosophies around this
then it's going to fail
it's gonna fail for men
and I think what men have to understand
is they can't put hope in the female
content creators they have to put hope
in the male concert creators because
we're the ones that have the most at
risk so yeah I mean I think women will
say I got red pill
but tomorrow
no no how female nature works tomorrow
well I don't believe in none of that
stuff no more yeah I've seen that happen
I can't even fault you for that like
I've seen that happen so when it's
convenient yeah but like I don't believe
that no more [ __ ] I've seen it happen so
I can't even I can't even follow I I
haven't done that myself
yet as we say when we talk about women
you use the words yet and right now at
any at the yeah well because we're we're
um
we're kind of like every day we feel
something different so yeah I understand
it so yeah that's why I'm not you
shouldn't be offended but but the thing
is I think what tends to happen is
because you know there's monetization
there's attention more women are willing
to say hey I believe this but then but
then they get tired of it because
they're not truly invested there's no
loss so they'd be like I don't believe
that no more and then they go moving on
to makeup channels and [ __ ] so now what
that that all that work that she's did
now has turned here's the thing most men
that come to these videos and this isn't
a slight them in that watching this
they're not red pill
right they're not they're they're simps
or their blue pills trying to find some
truth or they're purple people
there's not that many dudes that be like
I'm red people right they're not Red
Bull and so if I'm on the show I know
I'm all handsome and all that they might
watch for about 10 minutes but then when
they see a woman
they gonna sit in there and listen oh my
God look at you I wish my sister I I
need to find a woman just like you I got
right they just really purple people
they live in the Hope strategy
there ain't that many women that are
going to be hardcore red pill and stick
to it all their life
The Hope strategy is dudes really just
hoping they find the Unicorn right or
they hoping that that um they're gonna
find something that nobody else has been
able to be able to make happen right so
their their strategy which hope is not a
strategy but their strategy is to Simply
go I hope I find the best scenario
instead of working for it
or instead of like changing their
philosophy like okay I don't need that I
can find another life do you know that
most men
if you remove validation in women from
their life like women validating them
they wouldn't do a damn thing
anyone
let me sit right there [ __ ] on
themselves
they wouldn't even clean clean
themselves they wouldn't do nothing
they wouldn't do a damn thing they live
for women's validation like dudes would
go to uh what college you gonna go to
hey man hey we're going we're going to
this party or are they gonna be on any
holes there you know what I mean like
that's the whole incentive they're gonna
go to the gym to make sure yoga pants
[ __ ] are there all right they don't
do nothing yeah no I I did re I I used
to uh
do kind of promotions for like a bar at
my college and that's how I'd Market it
like I would tell the girls that the top
guys were going and I would tell the
guys that the hottest girls were going
yes and neither told me they were going
you told the other group yeah oh they're
gonna be some girls you know it's gonna
be 50 girls yeah that's their first
who's coming and so I I'd always respond
like oh and just mention like the best
like the most best looking like guys on
campus exactly and then I would mention
like the hottest girls like so they
would just and then it'll work out and
then they show up oh what we doing they
had they added a sausage fest all of a
sudden yeah and they're the girls didn't
show up yeah but you know this typically
a sausage fest yeah yeah that's
typically what happens of ladies night
right the lady night promotion back in
the 70s and the 80s they basically were
like women in free it will give you two
drinks that way men are gonna go show up
because there's women there right if
they don't if they charge the women full
entry fee and they charge them for every
drink and then no dudes bought no drinks
women ain't going to that [ __ ] and then
diversity men don't show up so when I
say dudes I'm not saying dudes are weak
for living for validation of women but I
do give men another life some other
things to aim for and that's the cheat
code that's the secret of life when you
find out and put women in their proper
perspective you get access to more women
can you explain that Mark most men so
let's go back to the girls that get that
that their their their boyfriends
cheated on them that don't leave this is
prime example
that guy he don't vow he's not validated
by those women he's figured out he might
be a football player he might be a Chad
he might be self-absorbed he's into his
life he got Hobbies he go fishing he's
involved in his life
other his life matters more than these
hoes but
as a consequence
right because we don't want a guy that
makes us the center of him yeah
you're my everything he's texting you
every day where you at pearly where are
you why are you here who's there you
know what I mean that's annoying right
but that guy keeps getting hoes
now these pickup coaches I hate them
they go around saying I you're validated
by women so they just want you to run
around and talk in 100 women and all
that [ __ ] I I think that's
ridiculous the the cheat code is get a
life
now guys that wish they were dudes like
that end up all day thinking about why
those guys keep getting the girls and
they never put two and two together
they'd be like because he's tall because
he's handsome yeah that has something to
do with it but it's the fact that he
doesn't put them first that guy puts
himself first and he keeps
yeah like selfish yeah but girls like it
yeah yeah
and he can literally put them he can
tell them what it is and she could go
I don't want that but most times she
goes I'll take it let's have a question
yeah all right a man has two girls yeah
he lies to one and tells the truth to
the other which one does he love
he lies to one and tells the truth to
the other
damn
I think whoever he's lying to he
probably loves yeah
yeah I think that's a good question
though I've never thought about that one
but
yeah that's interesting I would say he
loves whoever he's lying to he loves
right
yeah and he doesn't want to hurt the one
emotionally he knows that if he if they
if she finds out the reality then he's
gonna lose him right so the one he likes
to okay
um
how many bodies has too many bodies a
girl girl depends on my age okay
age 25 I would say
okay uh well I'm gonna come from an
older School perspective [ __ ] none of
these girls are gonna live up to these
numbers I'm just letting you know uh 25
I would say if she's married intentional
married three
um if she's over 30 uh Old Maid or
Spencer
a leftover woman yeah leftover woman
over 30 uh uh old old chick old ass mate
yeah old ass 30 year old maid okay all
right
yeah that's like the most common number
I've gotten I've asked guys like they
all say 10 10 yeah uh but I typically
don't really worry about body count yeah
that's that that's they all say too I
think it's a foolish argument I think it
body count matters to a man who doesn't
have a body count that's that's yeah
that's what everyone that's what like
that's what guys tell me is like if a
guy says too low then the other guys
will be like oh he's not getting yeah he
ain't getting nothing because I'm not
I'm not really threatened by that but
I'm also not trying to get married so
that could that could be it and even if
I'm dating or messing with somebody
that's under 25 I don't care what about
um would you ever get married again
absolutely not no no no no there's no
incentive for me to get married I mean
first of all I already have kids so uh
that's the number one reason why I think
people should marry if they intend to
have kids so I don't have to tend to
have kids at least not on purpose
um in the next few years of my life so
there's no need for me to get married at
that point it's useless if you don't
have kids
what do you think is the most
misconstrued thing about the red pill
why does it get such a bad rap
uh is the truth right so again people
want to live in fantasy so if I tell you
if I tell you things like romance is a
myth
who wants to hear that's you
if I say romance is a myth
um that's toxic to a lot of people
and if I'm telling men you don't need to
that that was meant for you essentially
that's going to be equivalent to
pornography for me like that's what I
make it and then men can get an
understanding yeah that's fake you know
but yeah that's why people people don't
want to live in that type of world I
think they don't know what to do with
themselves after that
most people are useless
in the world they're they're useless
they have to be told what to do every
day they got told be told when to wake
up
uh they're gonna tell one time to go to
Street uh sleep what type of your sports
team is playing uh what to do at work on
a daily basis most people need guidance
on a daily basis uh in essence you're
useless so in essence then if you're if
you're useless I got to tell you what to
do and how to make love and
and how to treat a woman and all that
stuff you know the guys your guys you
went to high school with that boned all
the hot cheerleaders and the chicks that
guy right there he's been living in this
truth
he's discovered a truth that men don't
discover until age 30 and 40 if at all
that all women are the same okay
most men at 18 ain't experience nothing
right I so it takes him up to age 30 35
40 sometimes 50 55 to be able to have
five women to go oh it was all the same
the dude that 16 17 18 running through
them he's in college running through
them he like these girls ain't it one's
differently
you don't think any girls are different
what do you mean but they're all the
same in terms of what you're what you're
getting from them the whole
transactional term of it right so some
girl is going to be like I'm special I
know my worth right she's gonna say all
that [ __ ] right and then you're gonna
take a route it's gonna be a dudge
you're gonna lay there on bed like a
damn Carl's Jr star like a dead fish and
you like
that ain't nothing right yeah yeah so we
have this idea that women are special
and they they increase in value over
time you know what I mean and she knows
meaning like I know my words so she
raises the value she raises the price as
you get older stop at the born-again
Virgin yeah that's enough yeah yeah
three
package themselves so when Chad was
[ __ ] you like you didn't give a [ __ ]
about God no no yeah they're born again
the Born Again peace
to me to me I know that these people are
worthless because I've gotten them not
worthless but there don't have the value
they perceive let's just put it like
that because I know people got hurt
feelings now they don't have a value
they perceive themselves to have so
what's going to happen is these people
are going to learn over time that people
don't see them as valuable then what
they're gonna be out here still talking
about they know they were 40 45 50.
nobody nobody's gonna take that dude
what do you so since you're you're 47.
so you have a bit more life experience
than me a little bit a little bit
you'll catch up fast ladies 40s right
around the corner don't act like I'm old
if you're 25 40 is in 15 years I want
you to think about that
it's 15 years along I guess when I was
25 you're like 15 years was a long-ass
time that [ __ ] happened yeah I was 10 15
years ago so you like that's a long ass
yeah 25. and then you're here
okay well so
yeah that was it I know I know yeah yeah
yeah yeah so my question was
um
what do you like what happens to the
like what what happens to like the girls
that sleep around and like do they ever
get married do they end up getting
married some of them do some of them
some of them would you say most two or
most just die alone uh if you die alone
yeah they they don't die alone yet 40 is
not death yeah but what typically
happens is most of them become left over
right most of them just go on the [ __ ]
Carousel and have their fun and then
they use relationships as a break from
the [ __ ] Carousel and they'll fall in
love and they'll post that person on
Facebook and Instagram you know but like
I finally found a step daddy for my son
and daughter and then they'll break up
they'll delete all the pictures that
[ __ ] is a vicious cycle right then by
the time they hit 40 and 44 they like uh
I'm living my best life and they'll be
they'll have money they'll have a good
job and they'll have a Mercedes C-Class
Mercedes and they'll they'll be balling
out of control they'll ball out till
they fall out then 50 hits
then they are done
done it's it's a disaster by then it's a
disaster what they're gonna hope now is
that some dude's gonna take that deal if
they ride it out to that most guys and
this sometimes happen mid-40s it just
depends most guys don't take that deal
and they just a single old woman
the problem is they say men are in the
same boat and that's not true
that men aren't that men are at their
Peak men are like going skyrocketing and
that's the dynamic they banked on men
being still the losers that they were
when they were 30. all these guys I'll
just settle down with these guys but by
40 between 35 and 55 for men is like
Super Bowl
we winning
we got choice now or at least and then
it's like what fine why yeah well in
essence our big head out thinks a little
head
or we've been manipulated or we've been
burned right or we've been finessed so
now we're like oh we see what y'all
doing and then women in our state age
group they still trying to run the same
Playbook
be like we know what that [ __ ] is like
don't try to run that [ __ ] on us that
ain't gonna work and then they wonder
why men why aren't these men committing
to you I could go down to the junior
college
and I could have me some fun all right
with a younger woman
that's that that's the junior college oh
okay yeah yeah okay okay okay
I'm learning so many terms today yeah
yeah
I'll I'll say that when people come on
my shell be like you're at the junior
college you're in the junior college age
range yes yes yes and and typically
older men we get the junior college
girls under the cover of night we send
them back to the dorm after we're done
with them
oh sometimes
oh okay
okay
if my dad
these girls are like like you need to
use it for his money I'm like I'll just
go to my dad make Dad pay for her Poor
Dad Dad man stop giving up no no hey
he's happy
he's had like what he'd rather have me
streeting look that's why I'm gonna tell
you if you have a daughter I always tell
men if you have a daughter pay for her
give her money
what I'm saying yeah
give her money hey dads if you don't
give your daughter money she gonna find
it somewhere in some way you don't you
don't want her to get it
well I would I I like to think I
wouldn't but I always say all women have
or have thought about
going to get some money
no I've just been really privileged like
I don't most people don't grow up like I
did most people most people's parents
don't get water slides right right yeah
most people don't do that yeah so you're
in a privileged position yeah but um
yeah most people aren't most people went
broke as hell
yeah so these girls out here in the
street and they serving you know men
like me you know you know we take we
take them out and show them a good time
see you have like sugar babies do I have
sugar babies I don't I don't call them
sugar babies we just call them Junior
College
but they're basically sugar babies but
yeah
all women toward an Ascent are
transacting access to them how many do
you have
I don't keep them on I don't keep them
you know what I mean yeah yeah we have a
we have we have freshman orientation and
sophomore graduation every week
yeah every week There's a new
orientation coming in yeah so you know
what I mean it's like we don't wait by
semester we just wait for the week oh
yeah
she learning some stuff here yes we just
wait by the week every week you know a
girl goes broke
every week a girl gets evicted every
week a girl need a new pair of shoes
every week a girl needs something you
know she needs she every week the girl
goes hungry you know so at that
particular Point hey you need a little
bit of you you need something other than
that Top Ramen you know what I mean and
then we we have a little fun and she
gets to fill up a refrigerator
yeah came to the wrong place he thought
she was getting it she thought she was
gonna get softball stuff at that point
so see you give her cash
oh everybody there's no cash transaction
we don't deal in cash transactions sure
she gets a refrigerator you know
uh oh okay okay
I stunned her I stunned him silence yeah
okay
um
go in more you got some more about the
junior college
okay wait so how many so is okay how do
you devise women like let's let's just
so there's a junior college woman and
she's after a junior junior college
women there's
um we have seven levels of qualification
I teach men the seven levels of
qualification so the first level is do
not qualify all right you don't qualify
that's level number one all right uh the
next level hold on for a second
she she a busted Pillsbury biscuit can
all right she's she ain't she she don't
qualify all right so I'm gonna go down
to my Seven Levels here I gotta get it
right here there it is right there all
right so uh level ones do not qualify
qualify number two is service provider
like she can give me something I don't
want to keep her around for long
so she can give me some there's
something I want from her I gotta find
out how I can get that sometimes it can
be money sometimes
wait she wants it from you or you want
you yeah you want money from her no no
no I want her oh okay and then you have
to figure out what she wants what do you
want okay okay money attention money
energy attention on time like what is it
so then she's providing the service but
I ain't keeping around for long practice
okay practice for your wife no practice
for six all right she just I meant like
like this is
what oh she practicing for my wife yeah
so yeah not you not you in particular
you're not gonna get remarried no yeah
but like but for others it's like
practice for them yeah she practiced
like like you'll be like okay let me
just work on a couple of things with her
yeah yeah but she is that's just gonna
be it I can't practice dating her but I
can practice just just being in bed with
her she practiced a lot of girls are
practice
they get treated like breakfast what I'm
telling you most guys do instinctively
but women don't notice but I'm just clue
when people in uh the fourth level was
going to be she's a part of your con
your concubine or your Harem okay which
people will call rotation okay
yes okay good good yeah so she's in my
rotation she's a concubine
but a concubine can be gifted and taken
care of that's what so she could be like
like a a top-tier yeah but she's still a
cocky she's still a Kamikaze
know your place
you might buy her dinner
oh she's making her rent page
oh okay but but you're still concubine
you ain't gonna you're not moving in all
right the next level is a regular this
is a friends with benefit right so she's
a regular Oh I thought the last one was
I thought that was the like what's the
difference between a concubine a
concubine I might not have access to all
the time I just have her on the side NBA
players typical are a sports celebrity
might have a concubine in each City he's
not with her all the time but he has her
just for himself when he needs her
regular
regular is like I see you every week I
see you two times a week right that's a
regular but a concubine typically could
be like a woman will say she lives in
Toronto and she'd be like I'm dating
some player who plays for the Lakers
well that can't be possible how often
does that player in Toronto very little
right but in her mind she's dating that
player that's a concubine
she don't see that guy a lot but a
regular is somebody I see and I'm with
this message so how often do you see a
concubine how many times
the market
so so this is something
you mean you never see her you have to
see her wants to make her a concubine I
can not necessarily so let me tell you
how kings have used concubines like this
is a real education for a lot of people
people will use these terms and they
don't know what they mean a a king or
somebody who's Noble or who has access
to women typically will take women off
the market so they're not defiled by
poor men right so that maybe she might
have a later use maybe she might be a
surrogate maybe I might want to
impregnate her right because I look at
her she has value but I'm gonna take her
off the market because I'm valuable
enough to do so but that don't mean I
have to see her own all the time right
right you're beautiful
sometimes but I would imagine you think
so but she's getting supported oh okay
so it's concubine the support a lot of
times men don't they use this term
concubine as a [ __ ] those are two
different things oh
a regular might be a girl that I'm just
hooking up with and hey I see you every
week every two weeks okay okay she's
irregular a pretender is a woman who
thinks she's white material okay
she ain't okay
this is the born-again Virgin they're
born again yeah
that's
it
a panel the other day with one of the I
I know I know the archetype yeah you
know the archetype so she'll have men
she'll have babies by other men one or
two or three maybe more and she'd be
like I'm a wife and I'm like waiting for
my husband [ __ ] yeah that she's a
pretender never take her seriously okay
and the contender will be that girl like
I could marry her final round draft pick
she's the top tier draft pick I want to
marry her I'm gonna pull her off the
market we're gonna be together Contender
but that is a rare
most everybody you're meeting is either
a concubine Harem she's a hooker [ __ ]
or she's a pretender or she don't
qualify
that's the reality of it so people that
when men see you men don't have to see
you for very long to put you in these
guys
ah so if you're wondering why you're not
getting wifed up probably look how you
present yourself so oh
so it's been one of the oh I wanted to
see I wanted to see the other one so are
there more uh well no that's just a
several of it most of these are just
like the banners I put up for my show
like interesting ones on
um no this are there any other terms I
need to learn
um so this is a junior college these are
the levels of the junior college no this
is a level for all women okay Junior
College
18 to 26 maybe extended to 28. oh
yeah
and then oh here I got something to show
you well I don't know if it will pop up
on your screen I won't show it on your
screen so here's your age groups right
here how I've oh wait a minute so put
them up right here so here it is right
here so 18 uh 16 to 20 in some places
16s whatever it's young and dumb all
right young and dumb uh when when you're
young and dumb you get the chances to
make mistakes right we all get to make
mistakes but of course the women's time
clock is a little bit shorter don't be
out here doing stupid stuff until you're
25 you're gonna fumble the bag all right
uh 21 to 24 this is your Mrs degree
right you should be searching and in
general based on the rules of nature you
should be searching for the man you're
going to marry meaning your behavior has
to start reflecting marriage if that's
your intention now just because you can
Botox and implant yourself and put bbls
and go out here and ride the Carousel
and move to another city acting like you
wasn't hole in the last City uh go get a
degree and all that [ __ ] you can do all
that [ __ ] but that's all modern
conveniences right I can microwave my
food every day but that don't mean
that's healthy right the clock is still
talking the biology
yeah
lots of tickets yeah okay so that's
that's going to be what you should be
doing between 21 and 24. oh so I'm at
last call yeah yeah so last call 25 to
28 that's when what you're doing is this
this is it you miss the window of the
Prime select men now the men you're
getting at last call
yeah all right you can do something with
them okay you can do something so it'll
be lower but it's gonna be you yeah you
ain't you know what I mean like they
already done wife up the wife of boards
right but now you bout to be like you
better put it out there okay uh what is
going to be oh after 29 29 and 36 that's
Hail Mary time oh okay because it's like
it's like the yeah oh [ __ ] yeah I better
uh the clock's running out three two one
half court yeah half court because you
know what's happening now is you missed
out on the guys who were willing to get
married when they were young and dumb
right when men didn't have no idea what
the hell was going on right so now men
have smartened up at by 30 and 35.
they're not going to fall for the okie
doke and you're waiting for the next the
only available men are going to be men
that were marriageable and uh men who
escaped or men who got divorced and had
other family so a woman in her mid-30s
is probably going to get a guy who's
actually been in a long-term
relationship and or divorced and you
already kind of Tainted you can't get
tricked so that's what that next level
is and then 37 to 34. where did all the
good men go and when they say in your
20s yes yes that's where they back there
yeah or they were aboarded
yeah that's another conversation that
people don't want to have yeah so so the
reality is where did all the good men go
uh they was back there when you're they
were back there
16 to 2028. 45 is the new 25. so when
they passed you know that 40 they're
they're in their mid-40s yeah they were
like they still walk around here they'll
dress like they're younger you know
they'll get implants or uh they'll do
some [ __ ] and they'll be out out there
at the club talk about 45s it's the
older women that get the boob job right
now that I think about it it's like
putting new rooms
look at these nice shiny rims
I'm a long-term thinker I'm like you got
it you're not going to be 80 with those
in yeah
by the way you need to redo those every
10 years which is a cost
I've seen two there's people walking
around with them at ADL and here's the
thing
here's the thing
um you got to redo them every 10 years
and typically women who get married and
they get breast implants after they've
had kids they get divorced but then they
don't get the redo so I've been with
women who got uh busted up boob jobs and
one sagging down worse than the other is
a disaster all right so
and then after that game over all right
game over 53.50 it's really 50. game
over
game I mean nobody you ain't but now
they might give you hope I'll find me
okay you live in the whole strategy now
you could get one but it's game over
here and then they'll always say well I
I know someone that did exactly but it's
like I know someone that won the lottery
exactly I know somebody that met uh her
husband on master.com her third husband
well yeah well is that gonna happen to
everybody no so they're they're you know
living on the prayer at that particular
point but uh I know people you know they
get disgusted at what I'm saying but
it's true no I mean I could I mean let
me see this one yeah you just worried
about you on your last call
last call you got a couple years left
so you better you better smarten up yeah
Hail Mary time
she buzzer beat her time you want to go
back to the buzzer like uh six misses
degree Mrs degree so you're preparing
yourself for that you these are women
that go to college right yeah yeah I did
go to college but here's what here's
what women in college age basically used
to do in the past so my mom told me to
get your Mrs degree right that's what
she told me so you're you're women men
and women when you're in college the
people that you're surrounded by are
always in your age group yeah right and
that like 80 90 of the people you
associate with are in your age group
once you get out of college it it's not
like that anymore right the only way you
find that is at a nightclub everywhere
else the men are either older or super
young it goes right that so your
pickings get Slimmer just just leaving
the college campus your best point is to
get with people and attach them you know
what I'll tell you where I fumbled okay
yeah I fumbled it back yeah I'll tell
you what at my first college it was like
they called it it was
I transferred okay because because of
sports okay okay super easy to transfer
but I did that's true all the time I
coached Sports so college sports so I
know you were like I'm gonna go to this
school and ball out yeah I didn't like
my coach at my first school yeah it's
kind of a dumb reason but I was thinking
I was like at that school it was like
it was like the the ratio was off but it
was better for the girls
always better oh I see so they had they
had more pickings yeah no like the like
girl like it was 60 meant 40 oh that's
rare
his degrees were really good it was like
engineering that's rare yeah
because you went to the new school the
new school
it was like 70 women or 65 it was it was
good I was like I was like oh wow so if
it was like at the first school like
yeah you should have stayed there yet
yeah yeah
yeah man that's a bad time for you women
your age what to get married what do you
mean it's tough enough
well actually I don't know
what the legal part I like the more I
learn about the legal part like like get
it signed by the state I'd like to have
like I don't know I think about this
because I have mixed feelings because I
understand why guys yeah I understand
why guys don't want to get married
okay but I feel like as a girl like if
you have kids like you want to have like
some you go this is the switch up now
some level of commitment but I think
like I was thinking about it I think I'd
be cool to just like some sort of
ceremony or something without the state
I don't know I have to think
look women gonna switch hey guys women
gonna switch up on you bro so typically
this is what I tell guys once whatever
she says
before the marriage ring and the kids is
not what she's going to say when the
marriage ring and the kids come
they she turns into a different woman
because of naturally she wants to have
the kids survive everything she does is
for those kids and every every bit of
love she thought she knew
is doesn't compare to the love she has
for that kid and the kid has for her so
she might this is why I told me don't
listen to what women think of love
because it ain't even a love yet when
she experienced childbirth and she she
has kids that's the love and then she's
gonna have a different priority
so you might say you don't want to stay
from the marriage but then when you have
kids you're gonna be like well how are
these kids are going to survive if I get
divorced you're going to have a
different mindset that's it what do you
think for your so you're it's
interesting so you have a daughter do
you think she should get married I have
a son too yeah yeah so yeah if someone
asked me this question right and I said
if I had a daughter I'd say that's the
son I'd say no oh so I see what you said
well this is typical because you want
the daughter to be taken care of right
right
yeah I don't I don't know put it like I
just feel like there's like a level of
commitment once you get married like I
think it's better for kids to be in a
two-parent household but it's like even
today it's so easy to get divorced so
what do we do that's what that's my
whole point is again these marriages are
temporary right they're very temporary
so they're like do you want your
daughter to get married do I want to get
divorced because that's coming that's
going to likely come so do I want to see
my daughter hurt in that manner to get
divorced of course
oh well if she got divorced because she
left most likely yeah but they're yeah
so do I want when women get divorced
they are putting themselves in a
position that is going to be detrimental
to them long term
getting married and divorced that's like
that's like the clock strike midnight
your life is going to be forever tainted
yeah now she gonna try to patch it up
and they act like she living her best
life but when she in the kitchen having
dinner with her dog
and then eventually when she gets old
enough where she eating the dog food and
then when there's no more dog food she
eating the dog yeah yeah so is your
answer no then or yes
oh by the time how old is she she's 16.
oh she's 16. yeah so you think marriages
what do you think of the data set that
women between the ages of 18 the women
that get married before the age of 25
have higher divorce rates
I've heard that I've heard the opposite
too yeah I see it I think it's below it
might be below 22 or 21 like the young
the young people get divorced and I've
actually heard the longer you wait wait
the the more uh
right right
so the the day the data the data I've
seen it's like between 25 and 30 is the
longest lasting ones I'm just curious
yeah and I'm just wondering if we're
gonna say the same thing as I the reason
I think
um here's the here's the secret okay
okay
um a successful marriage is in a
marriage that stays intact I'll repeat
it a successful marriage isn't a
marriage that stays intact a successful
marriage is a successful marriage so
just because two people stay together
typically when you get married older
you're basically a little more wiser
you're like I don't have any more
options I got married to push these kids
out in 2.5 years right so you're on a
speed up clock and you get married and
you're like all right I'm gonna make
this work right I don't want to go back
out there dating so you're gonna stick
you're going to stick together some of
these marriages are miserable behind
closed doors they so people say because
you stayed together
I mean I wouldn't say success but I just
like how else would you measure good
versus bad you measure it when one or
both people dead and they're still
together that's marriage what do they
say in marriage what do they say in
marriage exactly so that's when you
judge the marriage did they stay
together until they did yeah yep success
so but what I was gonna say with them
they should be screwing each other
the the before the the and I'm
butchering it so I know I know I'm not
saying it right but I know there's like
some study and I know it's like
incredible okay before the age it's like
people that get married before a certain
age are more likely like they're the
most likely to get divorced but I think
it's because the women today like The
Virgins today are not the virgins of
yesterday and it's like even if they're
virgins which is like the ideal they
still hear the whole stories and they
might feel like they missed out and then
they might divorce their husband before
the party that's right so that's
typically like 32 they like oh I miss my
younger years yeah
that's common that's common actually my
ex-wife said that when we were again she
was like I missed out on my younger
years because I think she was 25 when
I'm married right so she he she
intentionally her intention was to have
a family and a husband
but as I said women are going to change
their mind and once she got that she was
like well I already got that so I'm
gonna go out there go back and party
because I missed it now what so I'm
sitting there like what happened to my
wife yeah and that's that's the the kind
of that's why I think you're right with
the rolling the dice because it seems
like you could get the quote unquote
like perfect girl she could be a virgin
but even like I I had um a show on
virgins like virgins versus hoes
something like that and you know
obviously like the Virgin is better but
the one comment that I kept getting is
like I dated a virgin but then she got
curious and laughed dude you're right
yeah you're right I always tell guys
they're like they're they're like there
needs to be more versions but the the
trick with the virgins is that they once
they're with you they're gonna wonder
what if
uh Mr excitement I want to go out there
so that's no guarantee
that's no good that that doesn't protect
you because there's still nightclubs and
Instagram and and that's and that's why
it's almost like men really don't want
to get married because it's like before
at least they got loyalty they got yeah
and now it's like nothing right yeah I
think the marketplace is that women have
just too many options and when you you
study people who have very much options
foreign
unless you're over 50.
and that's where they get manipulated
they consider sexual attention
relationship activities
anything anything anything
well because it's not about the person
it's about the ACT we're just trying to
feel I feel good yeah like I even had
guys on my show I was like how many of
you have had sex with a girl that you
were embarrassed yourself with them and
they all right [ __ ] like 80 of people's
rotation is busted Pillsbury biscuit can
but that shouldn't be seen as a negative
biologically we're able to spread our
seed so we're we're just trying to feel
good and you know it's an advantage that
we have
so people want to count it as a negative
that guys will screw anything but just
think about it there's a lot of ugly ass
people here and babies need to be had
so somebody got a screw somebody's
screwing them somebody's throwing these
donkeys you like who screwed that ass
donkey ass moose and she running around
with three babies
so if most of the people are ugly by by
definition bell-shaped curve there's a
small percent of Attractive people and
there's some ugly [ __ ] people and
everybody in the middle is average
that means there's eight billion people
on the earth almost 8 billion a lot of
ugly and average ass people got screwed
and Pregnant
so looks are almost inconsequential
especially if the guy don't have much
choice
the other thing is they'll always say
average is an insult right the average
at best thing no even just in the
manosphere like people people say oh
she's average oh my God most people are
just fine I don't mind being average
yeah I'll be right average I know I
ain't all that so I look at it like like
people will say they're like women will
rate themselves I'm an eight or a nine
you're like man please like by
definition there can't be that many age
for nines and there's be some ugly
broads talking about the eight or nine I
like please but being a five I'd say
five and six is fantastic
that's fine for for most guys a five or
six perfect now when you did below below
five you're talking about undercover
night practice
50 year old women practice and by virtue
of being 50 you are not a nine you don't
even qualify past the five
once you're 40 really as a woman there's
no way you're above a five
yeah
like biologically you can't hit like so
that's a point you know you mentally
unstable that's a point you're
delusional that's a point and then go on
the looks point you got another man's
kid
point you just going down the rung how
many points okay if a girl's a 10 yeah
[ __ ] but she's a kid what is she what is
she she's the four four six points
marriageable
um
she's a 10. but but she slept with 20
guys
30 guys yeah she's a 10. I would give
her eight she might be good at it
eight or nine she might be good at
sleeping with me and I might want to get
work yeah
oh for a girlfriend
oh I see I thought I was just practicing
no no she's a 10 but she's what slept
with 30 men oh girlfriend style oh damn
30 men I'll give her a seven
tins are rare
but we also have to know she probably
slept with men for money and old men and
sugar daddies and [ __ ] like that so and
NFL players so yeah
I thought you'd do more actually I
thought three three uh three I was like
I was like these women got 30 bodies
ugly ass chicks got 30 bodies so what we
doing
and and women that are nines and tens
they're basically in the model category
so they're hookers essentially they've
been belonged to the market they've been
transacted directly for money in various
ways modeling
they've used their looks and body to
transact that's definitional hooker so
if she's an Instagram model she's a
hooker she's just an e hooker okay so
that's a transaction
okay yeah okay or she has the only fans
he's a hooker right so at that
particular Point nines attends tend to
have been transacted theirselves they've
had sugar daddies they've been flowing
out they had newspaper tuition she been
a model she was a spokesperson she's a
fitness trainer slash these are e
hookers so
this is what I consider nines and tens
yeah I still bro I'll still practice
with them and they might be a part of my
concubine now Harem but yeah but they
ain't getting wife yeah yeah no wifing
material yes so then okay so she's a 10
but
she's got an attitude I can't deal with
women with attitudes
um is she snarky or sarcastic she's a 10
yeah that's gonna be like a seven I'll
give you give yourself
okay so it's interesting the the body
count and the attitude it's like the
same but yeah
yeah well those things are qualities
that women think are endearing
like uh now they're like oh God guys
want me and uh and if they're snarky and
all that stuff the attitude stuff and
and that I don't deal with that very
well actually I've developed a second
archetype of people on the shows so
there's a type of guy that kind of likes
girls that are mean to him I don't know
what I don't know what it is but and
like guys guys will say okay this is
manosphere we'll be like no no we want
fit feminine friendly and I'm like okay
healthy man maybe but I'm like there's a
portion of men
that like girls that are mean to them
and I can't explain it but I've seen the
archetype because it's like I'll see the
guy he's got options he's a good looking
maybe you should know it I don't know is
she attractive though what what is the
woman attractive with the attitude oh
there you that's why that's that that's
why there's a donut the attitude that he
could certainly date yeah
you're saying they're pretty the girls
that he can date that are pretty and he
don't want I I don't disagree with you I
don't disagree with you I think I think
you're I think men do typically go
afterwards a lot of times like they
didn't have like a dad like I've just
noticed it a lot of times they don't
have like those guys they don't have a
dad and so it's like they kind of look
for their mother I think I think this is
like my woman's interpretation of it
could be I don't yeah just an archetype
seen it over and over there's guys that
yeah I mean but these are younger guys
right yeah okay I was gonna say yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly it gets old younger guys are
typically that's something or maybe the
girl's like a predator and he's just
like I don't know
I think the girl knows how to manipulate
him and make him feel good when you've
like when when she's with him yeah he's
like this is Euphoria same thing with
women and then when it's bad he's like
yeah but she makes me feel good you know
what I mean she tickles his balls just
right so he's like there's nobody that
does that and so I need to keep her like
that so yeah and then if she's
attractive he'll put over more [ __ ]
I always tell guys get you a six
six
aim for sixes okay they be out here in
these streets too but but six sixes
sixes one out of seven yeah
um why not a seven let's break down the
girls fight by the Rings yeah it gets
tough you know standard of beauty but
ten nine and ten belong to the
marketplace they will be transacted
amongst men in a variety of ways yes
some web some of them will become wives
and hot soccer moms right and you'll be
like damn that doctor but the only
reason why she's with him he's a doctor
right but that doctor has the Super
trophy wife that's what hot girls become
you know very attractive women become
they become transacted
Suburban wives so seven and eights
eights or one of B nines watch out for
eight days
so
eight don't have it what it takes they
might be want to be a model but they're
five three you know what I mean like
they they want to be a supermodel one
but but they're short you know what I
mean but they're still attractive it's
like they could maybe get a low level
modeling contract
it's low level you ain't getting you
ain't cat walking you ain't getting the
runway but she lives in Tupelo
Mississippi right you know what I mean
and she's like man I'm gonna go to New
Orleans or Dallas and make it in the big
leagues that's a eight she's a wanna be
nine be careful with them they're tricky
they're tricky they they want to be
treated like the nines and the tens but
there's always going to be she thinks
she's gonna get what the pretty girls
that she sees that are nine to ten
slightly more attractive with her she
wants that and she's gonna keep missing
and missing and missing until she
adjusts her idea and uh she's also not
gonna sell herself like the nine or ten
she's not not gonna sell it well she
can't she can't wait she's she's good
for that oh okay
okay so the nines are tens they're like
ah the Nigel tens will be on First Class
getting flown to Aruba okay right I
ain't doing that with that old man like
she's gonna put up a fight I got two
standards right she's gonna put up a
[ __ ] bike right and so it's dangerous
okay seven sevens kind of don't exist
they muddle you know what I mean it's
kind of a non-existing area okay yeah
you're in that the Kevin said it's like
he's Kevin Samson so and I have to agree
with him because it's easy to say
everybody's a seven and I actually did
it too but sevens are non-existent it's
a big drop off
sixes are gonna be what people will call
um an adjustable six right she could be
a plain Jane or she could be somebody
who can look like an eight if she tried
um She's Some Girls you might be
surprised she shows at the gym and
you're not you're like who is this and
then she gets dressed and puts her
eyelashes on and [ __ ] you're like wow
she's a knockout she's an eight so a six
can jump up in that eight territory but
she has a right mind she might have very
abilities in the city that's what I've
noticed like the people will call it
like two sixes can be completely
different it looks like one will be a
lot cuter but they're still sexy they're
still the Silver Six they could be
something wrong they build awkward yeah
let's not let's not get cocky Deborah
six is better than all day plays yeah
they do though and they should they
should know their place a six can also
be an eight that came down the same
thing
right she was she was hot she gained a
little weight she partied and [ __ ] she
got the raspy voice she smoked
cigarettes now oh damn she used to be
good and she aged yes outdoor you know
yeah I'll take her
so the sixes are in a weird territory
right like they're they're they were
they could be like a we called a late
developer a late bloomer where she was
ugly as hell until her senior year and
then she showed up all developed and she
learned how to put her makeup on you're
like oh you know what I mean like so a
six could be that's a six I always say
that's where you should aim because
that's where you're gonna have your most
success it's not aiming low though
five you still all right okay you know a
lot of fives get married
a lot of fives you see a woman she built
like a bowling pin and she could be
married right you can do well but you
better have an attitude if you think you
are a six five six six seven eight nine
and you're a five you're gonna be single
like a [ __ ] you ain't getting
yeah no the five they kind of another
place gotta know your place and you
better by not be home holding out here
okay there's no [ __ ] cares for yourself
for five for five they they can't they
don't do you throwing your life away
don't be a single mother don't act like
you got value don't act like you know
your worth you sit your ass down and
learn how to make these tacos you better
learn how to make that hamburger helper
you better know how to cook clean I
don't know how to cook take me out on
fancy dates [ __ ] yeah no no five so
fours once you go five once you go below
five
now you're aiming low
so fours are 49ers
fours are dangerous
because they are fours and they want to
be treated like nines they are
completely delusional really yes we call
them 49ers really wow so a four will be
out of her world delusional okay she
won't try to be a five
she'll be busted and try to be a nine
okay I'm gonna be an Instagram model and
yeah people will be following her and
all that [ __ ] and she'll you know a four
will be tragic it's a tragic case it's
tragedy
tragedy their attitudes are bad
they wearing hair weave and they're it's
tragedy tragic they're overweight by 200
pounds would you put the average at best
girl I would think I think of her as a
four she would be four yeah because her
attitude was off oh no I'd give her a
four like her face oh she was ugly
I'd say she's slightly below average she
was blowing yeah like if she was fat
she'd be like two things going for her
yeah so she's like a foreign but so then
she wanted the nine treatment she was a
49er she's a 49er she was like I deserve
a man that has this this and this like
like how would you get that guy like you
couldn't even be in the marketplace with
that you could he'll sleep with you
right
but you won't be seen with them very
much in public he'll sleep with you
three times and he'll be on you'll be in
a rotation of dudes
threes are gonna be I mean this is the
pit of Hell once you hit the three two
and one I mean you talking about you
know chicks homeless whales chicks that
Homeless chicks uh you know you're
dealing with bad ass I mean you're
dealing with women in wheelchairs and
[ __ ] you know I mean like you dealing
with the the bottom of the barrel bottom
of the barrel economically they're poor
they come from uh broken homes these are
people who smoke and they smoke do drugs
we they're completely pretty much
incapacitated
untouchable
men who mess with threes twos and ones
you're scraping the bottom of the barrel
and typically STI
they're gonna throw bricks through your
window they're untrained untrainable
ugly have you ever slept with the three
tour one
um
I've been around the block I've been
around here I know but
um I mess with some scapulin skis it was
in my time you know I had to I had to do
what I had to do you know but uh as you
say men will screw anything but uh yeah
man I learned not enough I just thought
four was like the bot no or it's not the
bottom because no Four's not the bottom
because I mean five
um yeah they don't have to be obese
there's a lot of skinny knock me trailer
park pieces of trash I mean there's a
you don't have to be fat
fat fatness is never prosperous so
that's three two or ones I know are like
obese that's a quality yes but but you
there's some other people who are three
twos and ones that like like she's a
mental case right like you know she
crazy that's a three oh okay I thought
we were going off the looks oh okay
um
okay yeah I mean fat you don't have to
be fat but yeah fat women are gonna
believe
but not necessarily five five and below
so that's single mothers single mothers
All the Way Gone is he down six points
for me yeah single mothers as long as
she's like a nine or eight then she's
below four yeah you go yeah you go
you're gonna be super hot in a single
mother like yeah no man then yeah you
dropping down like for me to deal with
you single mothers know I mean I'll hang
out with you I'll do all that stuff but
you're never getting the ring
never
yeah but you definitely ain't getting
away yeah
but they might try to believe they're
going to get the ring they might try to
act good for like six months in a day
right but I'll show you I'm different
I don't I don't care what you show me
you are not getting the damn thing from
CGA hold that too oh my gosh it was
crazy I had a single mom of myself who
said she would not submit to a guy
unless he made six figures and I was
like well she was a single mom yeah with
like three kids anybody that uses the
six figure
I won't do this in less than six figures
that's a red flag
odds are they don't even know anyone
that makes six figures
legitimate six figures
it's Escape it's a red flag so
that's like me saying breast size or
some [ __ ] like that you know what
because you know what I ask I ask would
you quit your job if you told you to
actually I feel like that's like
ultimate submission right as if you
trust him right and the way they like
they'll go through all this stuff and
like be like no no he has to make this
much money but I'm like girl you can get
another job
yeah there's a few like you can get it
oh yeah you can get eventually you get
another job right you're right right
again but if it doesn't work out like
literally do you get you
yes that's two form of submission this
is she if she quits her job she's
serious about you number one and number
two uh if she direct deposits her
paycheck to your bank account
um
I feel like if you trust him with um
your body I feel like you should be able
to trust him with money your body is
more valuable than freaking money right
right yeah not anymore but I get what
you're saying again not anymore we trash
our bodies in various different ways but
yeah I get what you're saying
yeah women typically are throwing their
bodies around here recklessly and they
think that some reason guys are going to
overlook that and some men do but it
doesn't it's not the man that they want
well when you think about it all men
kind of do because like
what
1950s for
School guys who pray for that nowadays
yeah guys guys have prayed in Jesus she
says too he's like what I couldn't
believe it yeah yeah fair fair enough
you know what I mean but she grew up in
Los Angeles
yeah yeah but you see what I'm saying if
it was legit
so it's like in a way all men kind of
accept it because like Again by 1940s
30s 20s standards everyone's a horror
correct so we're living in horror
culture horror culture that's what we
live in a horror culture and uh yeah
that's what we're we're facing the
consequences of that women can't get
married or women are struggling
struggling getting married and men are
cautious of women everyone give all
these baby mamas raising children I
swear to God I get so confused after my
shows I swear to God I've been ruined
I've been ruined because these girls
would come on the show and they'll talk
about their stuff
and they'll leave and I'll what I do is
before the show I do a picture with them
and I tag them in my story
oh yeah I'm nosy sometimes I follow them
if they're kind of cool yeah yeah and
the girls
why is your ass on Instagram you've got
a son oh right yeah and then I'm like
I'll see their stories and I'm like why
are you out three days a week where are
your children
where are your children I'm like my
mother and she was out clubbing I would
be mortified right if you were a kid and
you knew your mom was out clubbing yeah
right yeah well these are hookers by the
way
these were hookers oh the singles I was
just I was shy I put that on my story
the other day I'm like oh y'all have
single moms going out three days a week
where are your children and then my next
story was if you pass on your kids to
your parents then you are selfish and
you're making someone else deal with
your problem and and everyone and
everyone responded to this story like
this was crazy I'm like
and you know who will be absent the
father
yeah in most cases those women will
fight the father to be out of that kid's
life and fight for child support and
that kid you could when you ask where's
the kid when you're out three days a
week nine times out of ten it'll be with
her parents not the father
that's the other thing I realized was a
lot of guys like want to be in their
kids life but they can't because of the
lot like because the child's like the
system is so messed up and I didn't
realize that there's a whole generation
of like mothers that like it you kind of
heard the deadbeat dad narrative but it
really wasn't the deadbeat dads it was
the crazy the bitter mom yes the bitter
mom yeah most I always say most men
found out they didn't have a deadbeat
dad they had a better mom
and so when you find out you had a
bitter mom as an adult you look back and
you go wow you know it's an epiphany for
a lot of men and of course then you have
to arrive do you want the truth
or do you want to live the lie I think
your dad has an [ __ ] like kids aren't
stupid they're gonna grow up and see
that you're a hoe at some point they're
not dumb well women don't think that far
ahead they don't think that far in
advance so they don't think the the
repercussions of that and um
unfortunately kids are getting damaged I
think we're doing so much damage to kids
today and um most of it is because we're
selfish men and women but um when it
comes down to these relationship things
we're selfish we don't put the kids
needs first and we think kids are dumb
and we can hide these things from kids
not really your kid's gonna see you for
who you are and uh you might think that
you can pass this BS and overall men oh
they'll see the value eventually you
know they want and your kids are going
to see that you're a piece of [ __ ] in
the scum of the earth and the scumbag or
a skeezer or deadbeat dad they're gonna
see you see it
the truth comes out eventually
eventually
God I
I yeah you got the truth
I don't think I'm nice anymore right
well yeah so you're bitter you you
you're the you're the equivalent of
bitter male
so you guys
I I was like whisper but this is what by
the way we have to deal with these type
of women on the very basis now you deal
with them yeah right right
I've been traumatized yeah yeah and I
always tell I want people to answer this
question if you're watching this
um answer this question women typically
don't like other women right it's kind
of known that women defend other women
but there's an instinct that kicks in
where women don't like other women if
they'll do any cat fighting and fighting
kind of manipulative okay now absolutely
now
the question is
if that's the case if women don't like
women
why should men like women
why
yeah
right
why would because people naturally think
we're supposed to like them the question
is why
why well we don't like other women
because
I feel like well
why
I think women I think like me included
it's like we look for things to get
irritated about sometimes
yeah okay that's fine yeah and so they
use it I I take they basically then use
us if we're in a relationship with them
as the emotional team yeah you basically
have to absorb all their [ __ ] which is
yeah basically but that's a modern
convenience
most marriages and relationships you
might be lucky if you saw your man
like men were blazing Trails they were
trailblazing they were exploring they
were building hunger and Gathering they
were building skyscrapers
like they were doing stuff
and you were settled down with multiple
kids nobody had time for this [ __ ]
see we already live in a safe secure
environment now like men were at War
they were battling they were learning
how to make weapons and defending like
you were just sitting up under each
other or cuddled up afterwards ain't got
time for that [ __ ] so we can literally
just be like all right the woman acting
funny I'll just go out to the shed and
learn how to you know you know I'll go
build the shed
you know I mean yeah
I'll go build a bathroom outside you
know what I mean I'll go kill an
alligator I'll go find something to eat
like you can get away from her now but
we got fruit in the refrigerator we got
everything right here so what else am I
gonna do after work sit up under her
I my opinion is I call it the law of
diminishing return
the more you spend with a person the
more the the relationship or the time's
gonna be messy messed up I agree at some
particular Point you're gonna hit this
line you're gonna be like when you see
each other oh you're happy uh then
you're gonna hit that point where every
minute minute spent is gonna be effed up
it's gonna be an argument
misunderstanding miscommunication
malfunction you're bored she wants to do
something she farted you know what I
mean like yeah so yeah
yeah I I could see that yeah so the
longer it goes the worse it's gonna get
yeah
people overstay their welcome yeah yeah
so it's not looking good for us ladies
we gotta we gotta we gotta stuff up our
game by the way I don't I'm not in the
business of correcting women so I I say
Let It Burn yeah I wanted to all Karma
down
I will let that All Fall Down okay what
would that look what would that look
like I think is going to be the uh
Venezuela 2.0 I want it to be chaos you
know why
this is how you learn
you learn when you hit your head I agree
actually I I if if this is If I Was
President okay Pearl for president I'm
leaving the country okay no you would
like my presidency I don't let women
leave me no okay well I actually agree I
first of all I'd give back our right to
vote I feel like we should well that's
interesting we don't even know where we
want to for dinner you want us to pick
the leader of the Free World nayski and
then they'd be like but you're in office
and I'm like oh there you go too bad
yeah
no no this is what happens okay that's
step one I would get rid of our right to
vote step two Advanced birth control
that could be that's yes yeah I would
ban it I don't mind that yeah yeah for
real most guys are like no not birth
control you may need to step up yeah so
then step three would be
um
single mothers getting paid to be single
you'd get paid for having kids in one
lock
no I probably wouldn't have any but I
just I I I have I'm bitter about this
law I found out about this law and I'm
like well I didn't get pregnant where's
my money anyways yeah anyways no I would
ban all I would ban child support
I would ban alimony I would ban all this
government [ __ ] nasiki NADA yes yeah and
I I can understand and you know what I
wouldn't even really have divorce laws I
would get rid of that like you pick your
poison you want to pick the bag stop
stop playing women we know we know which
guys are bad stop it stop it and stop it
oh I didn't know he was gonna cheat stop
it stop but do you know that most of
those guys don't get penalized
the abusers yeah they don't get
penalized it's the guys who were the
good guys who took a chance those guys
who want to see their kids those are the
ones that get screwed and divorced so
and then they end up being said that
they're the the abusers
you picked him stop it stop it stop and
I'm so tired of these women being like
Oh I had no idea he no he didn't no he
did it stop it stop it we know this is
all accountability usually at least
trying to hold women accountable for a
couple months but you shouldn't have
didn't have kid that soon right stop it
well these are really not I mean these
are guidelines that communities have
it's all gone yeah so what we have to do
okay is we have to let it go we have to
wait so you let the women
yeah they burn burn and then and then
you guys go for the next set of 22 year
olds yeah I would say we need a
correction we need to give people in
line we need to understand that we did
yeah we need to get we need to get
everybody in line stop taming the pool
of people uh generation after generation
but yeah man the only way we learn is to
see is to really find out what we lost
and I think as a as people as people who
grew up in democracies there's not many
democracies through democracies left for
republics and we're gonna fumble this
opportunity we're the first republic
since ancient Rome nobody's tried it
most of everything's been a dictatorship
and some sort of authoritative
leadership and whatever and everybody
told us what to do and everybody
followed or they got their head chopped
off right we have free will and we're
we're giving it back by making dumbass
decisions not why you see why there's
dictators
because people are stupid
with free will look at what we're doing
we're actually ruining it but like I
said it's got to go it's Gotta Go I
forgot to add my last thing that I would
do in power I would I would be like you
know what I'm a woman I shouldn't be
here and then I would have been I would
have a VP that was a man and then I'd be
like yup there you go all right make
sure you get all the powers in before
you abdicate the throne yeah yeah cause
I would just be like well I'm gonna get
my period next week I'm so like I would
just be like I could be crying I
shouldn't have the war button why am I
here you people stupid
I would give a whole lecture on why have
I been elected right why this is this
you guys are idiots but before that you
gotta cater to them you gotta get the
vote yeah go
no you know what and then I I have the
whole blue pill propaganda I could just
oh yeah women yeah it's college debt we
don't need that yeah forget and then
like when you get in yeah you switch up
on them but that'd be par for the course
that's what women do so jump on people
yeah yeah why not yeah yeah I just did
so now you can't do this now now you're
on videos I suppose I could cut
nah I'll leave it
that bad I don't want it either I don't
want anyone either
so I you know I leave it to you
I let it burn baby burn baby burn
well thank you for coming on absolutely
thanks for coming by the the uh we call
it the bunker
oh okay yes okay but you can't tell
anybody where this is because I'm the
Bruce Wayne of this I'm gonna be honest
you don't even know yeah yeah I don't
know yeah people think I always tell
people what city I'm in but I'm like you
ain't gonna find it
[Laughter]
she wasn't paying attention but it
wasn't it wasn't a short drive even if
someone asked you I'd be like I don't
know I was I was I don't know
did you enjoy the 911
I did that was my first portion I've
been in there you go yes or even my dad
had a Corvette growing up but I've never
been like a sports car before
minus like the Corvette but it was kind
of an old one so yeah
there you go yeah thanks for having me
thanks for having me yeah tell the
people where they can find it find me at
uh coach Greg Adams Channel that's my
big Channel my second Channel my
streaming channel is the free agent
lifestyle I'm there every day streaming
uh well not every day every weekday so
that's where you do it if you can find
me on Instagram they can find me there
find me on all these places where the
young people hang out and my old ass is
over there over there and guys go
subscribe because he got demonetized man
they need to monetize yeah yeah they
don't like CGA go there because I he
told me this Horror Story as my worship
yeah I want to pray to the YouTube oh
boy you couldn't be me because I've been
put through the whole thing I've been
putting some some very very very crazy
things on this platform yeah
um guys
on your way out subscribe to the channel
um also sign up for I have four
membership tiers and the fourth one you
get a one-on-one call with me once a
month I actually helped a lot of people
get to
um I've even help my friend Ally get to
100 000 subscribers I help people get
like ten thousand twenty thousand and
yeah I'm really good at social media
coaching so you guys should sign up for
that and like the video on your way out
and I'll talk to you next time